and today we're gonna be uh discussing
lesson number two how to design highly
available cost efficient fault tolerant
scalable systems
let's
skip straight to the slide number two
in today's sessions we are discussing
a few of the concepts
uh for example we're gonna be now we're
gonna know how to
uh
how to design cloud and what is actually
the difference between cloud and uh
normal infrastructure
um
as per this particular slide here
also we will know
what are the well architected uh
frameworks and what are the best case
scenarios and why
we'll be
discussing how to plan and design a
cloud infrastructure which kind of can
differ from a traditional
one on-prem
we also will be discussing monitoring
and logging tools available that we kind
of mentioned yesterday but today we're
gonna go a little bit more into details
which is uh really exciting and also
we'll be discussing a hybrid cloud
infrastructure what it is how we use it
and why would we potentially want to use
it
so straight away i'm gonna jump to the
next slide
to the overview of the design
um
in this in in this slide deck we're
going to be talking about overview of
the whole cloud design and all its
principles
so
designing cloud services
we will be talking about
um
frameworks
we're gonna be talking about four
fundamental pillars of aws which is
security
reliability
performance and efficiency as well as
cost optimization
we'll be digging a little bit more into
the searching for relevant information
where you can get it how you can search
for it and pretty much most up-to-date
sources you can get it from
we will also have aws quick start
reference deployments as well as final
real life examples and that particular
one here we will be digging into uh how
actually it is to log into the console
how it is to to start doing things which
i i know you cannot wait to do
so let me
skip to the next slide straight away as
well
there are five principles of
well-architected framework and there are
as following
stop guessing your capacity for your
needs what it is i will just i will
describe this as follows
basically if you think about the
traditional data center or you think
about on-prem servers and you have a
project to fulfill
uh you need to always plan ahead you
need to know how much hardware you
require you need to know the network
capacity you need to know the storage a
compute and many others
uh you need to pre-order this up up
front maybe you have already hardware on
site um however the the cloud is is
fully flexible you don't need to
pre-order anything you can click on i
need more resources more or less button
and you spin up more instances you will
spin up more storage you will spin up
more
uh more resources whatever required and
if you don't need it you can quickly
scale it down by decommissioning the old
servers or reducing number of uh storage
require hence paying less it's fully
scalable and whenever you need it it's
available to you
in
point two we have test systems as pro at
production scale this is very important
now why it's important is as follows you
want to test if the production system
will be able to handle specific amount
of traffic you want to test how it
actually performs maybe you need bigger
boxes maybe smaller boxes and it's
actually very easy you can deploy a
whole system with pretty much two or
three clicks that we'll be showing maybe
a little bit later
and you'll be able to create whole
environment by
basically following
simple next next next button and within
a matter of minutes you have production
scale environment which is exact copy of
your dev or or or qa
which is absolutely amazing
also you can lower
the risk of architectural change what it
means is because
in aws you can programmatically
change every single resource because
remember aws is a api
driven
infrastructure basically you treat aws
as a code you can program everything and
because of this
uh architectural change it's much more
difficult uh to be
to be to be
implemented by mistake or changed
because you reuse the same code so it's
not human error anymore
you can automate stuff which is the
biggest advantage to you guys there the
reason is
when you reuse the same applications and
systems and and trying to basically
build the same standards you can create
templates and those can be fully
automated which means you only commit
time once
and once it's done
you never ever have to
redo it again which is absolutely
awesome
and one of the last ones on the list
here is
uh allow evolutionary architectures what
does it mean imagine you have current
system that you currently supporting and
maintaining and it's great however there
is a change because someone wanted to
introduce a new
web service someone wanted to
to add additional database and that's
actually simple explaining additional
expanding current systems to additional
resources is extremely simple and it
doesn't require any
pretty much knowledge about what you
already have which is absolutely great
let's get to the next one
so stop guessing your capacity
imagine you are dealing with a new
application for your business
and all the infrastructure decisions are
made using
pretty much estimates or guessing
you might overestimate and end up with
buying too much hardware resulting in
expensive idle resources we all been
there we all know that those systems and
services that you're currently
supporting or working with they're
pretty much underutilize funny enough
um every single environment i worked for
and with
average
utilization of the system no matter if
it's one server or 100 servers was below
10 percent ten percent with the normal
hardware if you if you have the city in
your rack that's maybe acceptable
because you purchased this and you're
now using whatever you want to use in
the cloud however you think about this a
little bit differently reason because
you pay per hour as we discussed this
before which means if you're paying per
hour and you're only utilizing 10
percent of the resources
it doesn't calculate it it's not worth
it's much better to increase
um
an amount of
decrease server size or maybe decrease
the fleet of service or reduce number of
servers to utilize a whole stack that
you just spun out in a much much better
way
so for example i'm going to give you a
very very good one
we have a database
imagine that the database you have is
average medium size you notice that the
database itself is only using five to
ten percent of capacity
of this view and memory and you're still
paying for a whole hundred which means
you don't use it in this case you can
simply reduce size of this particular
database keeping the same data as it was
with a few button clicks really you wait
around five minutes and boom you have a
smaller server you utilize the server
now to maybe 40 50
which is kind of a sweet spot you always
want to be around and then you're
actually getting good value for your
money the same applies to networking the
same
the same applies to pretty much every
other field here which is absolutely
great and you're gonna find it that
managing costs suddenly couldn't be
easier one of the most common problems
people do and and quite likely you will
do the same at first is you will
overestimate the size of your uh
environment you will do
much bigger boxes that you actually need
the reason for it is you don't really
know what capacity you require for
application what systems are using and
in what way they're going to use which
is great at the beginning but after you
running production loads through them
and you notice that hey actually
databases are not used that much or or
maybe i have way too many web servers
you can simply reduce which means the
cost if you're gonna have a chart here
the cost suddenly can reduce reduce and
once you find the sweet spot
then the cost here is fraction of the
cost that you had it here
which is exactly what you're looking for
and you can do this over time you can
scale it up and down whatever you
require
i have a good question here from ravi
babu saying that sometimes we don't know
what the load will be and that's a very
a very valid question now
imagine situation we are running a store
online store and
that's gonna be a load chart here the
the load shot of your systems now that's
100 let's say 100
and that's time right
so your systems are kind of running uh
that's i'm gonna draw a days in here
no during the day your systems can be
used a lot during the night probably
less during the day a lot again during
the night less and that's kind of a
normal behavior but suddenly on this
particular day here you have a sale or
maybe you posted the link on the social
media which with a link to your store
saying hey buy it now and what happens
is suddenly you have a spike
quite likely on the old systems you
would reach this podcast point here and
pretty much that's it you would cup out
the capacity of your system and they
would stop working well with aws
you probably won't have this issue why
because you can use so-called
systems like auto scaling which means
that if your system ever detects that is
beyond
a specific level let's say 75 just to
make it safe
and that's the chart here if the system
detects that goes beyond for a specific
amount of time like three maybe five
minutes what it can do it can add
automatically additional service to the
pool which means the traffic suddenly is
being spread across much more service
which means the traffic you will notice
it will drop now you can also specify
this other way around which we're going
to discuss in the future if for example
the traffic flows beyond below 50 sorry
for my drawing
uh
what can happen is the auto scaling
itself can remove the service from the
pool just to make sure you're keeping
the sweet spot around here now that's
one of the uh of the uses of of the
system and that allows you to actually
have amazing cost saving especially when
you have a night
period that means that the number of
servers here can go beyond below let's
say maybe five maybe ten depending on
obviously what systems you're running
and you're saving money overnight
because you don't really have much
traffic yet you keep enough service in
the pool to have a redundancy so let's
say you wanna have at least maybe two or
three servers
spread across different ac's which means
if one's a server goes down it doesn't
really matter because you still have two
healthy ones and that's exactly what
we're trying to achieve and that's
exactly why you stopped guessing uh the
cost and the capacity
so
um
i have another question from uh
akshay
its number of servers does it mean
additional cpus
um yes in some way it does when you
think about the instance for a server
it's a it's a fix its server consists of
cpu
memory
and a hard drive
which means every single time you spin
up additional box and bear in mind you
can spin up different size of the boxes
you can have a small ones you can have a
large ones you can have different kinds
you will get guaranteed amount of cpu
memory
and and the drive and you can you can
make them smaller you can actually make
more of the same boxes which actually
means yes more cpu and more processing
power so yes that's that's um
those are exactly what we are talking
about
so
let's give to another one
we can test system at the production
scale
traditionally in a non-cloud environment
it's very difficult uh to actually
completely test new
products or services
in development and it's cause
is is is really difficult to guess
well project in this case projects will
go wrong as soon as the production goes
live between efficient testing and
that's very very common
with the cloud you can create duplicate
environments you can on demand uh to
test the new product after completing
the testing you can then shut down them
uh shut them down and you don't pay for
them which means every single time you
actually run any resource on abs you pay
for it every single time you shut it
down you don't you only pay for storage
if you're keeping anything so it's
actually a great great place and imagine
situation that
you can test if the if the if the
production system will be able to handle
specific amounts of traffic for example
your boss came to you and say hey
tomorrow we have a sale and i think
we're gonna have like 10 000 people on
the website could it could it handle
such such a such a such a traffic well
guess what we can easily spin up a whole
environment and
we can easily spin up the whole
environment at a specific size and we
can actually load test it with stress
testing tools or and to achieve maybe 10
000 visitors although let's say 24 hours
obviously 10 thousand visitors is not
the
big number but i imagine you have a 1
million you have 10 million or so for
you'll be able to test it ahead of the
time and if for example your tests come
back in 40 that the system can't handle
this well you will know where the
bottleneck is maybe the database is a
bottleneck uh
maybe the connectivity between a service
is a bottleneck maybe you need bigger
instances you'll be instantly be able to
tell
how well the production will perform
before you actually go into production
which is
extremely helpful as you all can imagine
let's go to another slide
uh sorry yeah one more thing we got in
this one
you can also create a duplicates of
environments in a very simple way and
that's one of the big advantages in the
traditional uh data center or on-prem
well you can't really create any
duplicates you have fixed amount of
service you can maybe dedicate few to to
non-production you can dedicate fuel to
others bear in mind those servers might
be different might they might have a
different cpus they might have different
capacity they might have different
drives some of them will have magnetic
some of them will have ssd
and all those things and performance of
this box could could be different and
you won't be able to determine the real
performance in the real time with the
aws you can duplicate the whole
environment with really few clicks and
you can deploy it multiple times across
the world if you want to and in this
case you have exactly the same copy of
all entire environment
just copy and paste simple as this
so another thing that is
worth mentioning is that you can lower
the risk of architectural change what it
means is with aws you can automate the
creation of test environments that
emulate your production configuration
which means you can carry out testing
easily against pretty much similar
environments
you can remove testing bottlenecks uh
when
teams are kind of you know testing them
uh with a base you can create as many
test environments as you really need or
want
you can keep it to minimum to be cost
efficient or you can spin up many
tests against qa you can test against
staging you can have different different
environments and that's the really
beauty of the whole
of the whole concept
i have a question um
i have a question from varvish uh um how
about uh
masking of production data if used for
non-production dev and qa do you have a
tool to do that it's actually very
when you say masking do you mean um
restricting or or hiding the production
from from non-production environments
or you want to reuse the same data as
production into non-production
environments which which which one do
you really mean
i'll be able to answer this question
okay so it's a highly in data from from
the
from a non-production environment uh yes
you can do this uh basically what you
can do is you can
duplicate the databases and you can drop
the whole schemas from the databases but
the whole concept video of testing how
it would behave from
in a non-production environment would be
to have exact copy most of the time so
you can actually test it on the real
data and as close to the production as
possible and that's the advantage of aws
you can actually take a quick copy of
your any system you want or any
environment duplicate it somewhere else
and actually run the test that would be
exactly the same and and that's the
video of it but yes you can actually use
uh different tools uh which i can
discuss with you a little bit later
because we're gonna be
doing a little bit more of of automation
other things so i can actually mention
this uh a little bit later as well
so
um
as i said
you can remove all the bottlenecks you
can find all the issues before you
actually go into production
so next slide automation it's extremely
extremely good
uh
and
once you actually go on to the aws and
you start using
aws automation you quite likely will
never want to go back to the normal
systems the reason why is
it's so simple and
you commit time only once to deploy
something and then you can basically
copy and paste the whole environment
again you don't have to set it up again
you don't need to deploy the same boxes
imagine
in your data center or on-prem you have
a bunch of servers someone asked you to
deploy a whole environment right and the
environment consists of
a few servers you have let's say two web
servers and one database server and
that's great you set up from from from
the beginning you basically purchase
hardware you install os you use all the
applications configure all the network
security you name it and then you
configure database completed with data
and all this stuff now someone told you
hey i actually want the same thing again
but this time it's not done in
production well guess what you have to
do it pretty much again yes you can use
maybe some script you can use maybe
automation books like chef and others um
which if you know how to use it it's a
great great thing but most of the time
because it's a small system like that
would be quite like it quicker to do it
by hand which is not ideal because quite
likely you're gonna do exactly the same
despite the fact it will try something
always is different with aws it's as
simple as you take a copy of this and
you deploy
copy
somewhere else and it's exactly the same
including all the data on the drives in
all the settings and all the data on the
database copy paste copy paste and
automation is exactly what we're talking
here about
um
i have a question from ravi babu
regarding what kind of tools generally
use for the automation in angular base
itself well
it's a it's a good question aws itself
provides you with uh
with a building system called cloud
formation that we will discuss in a few
moments
and the cloud formation is actually
a language that allows you to
pre-configure every single resource you
can think of in aws and basically deploy
it as many times as you want you can use
other other other tools like you can for
example if you have a aws ec2 instance
so basically a server what you can do is
you can convert it to so-called ami
which is actually an image of the whole
server and then once you have this ami
image you can deploy hundreds of them
and they're gonna be exactly the same so
whenever you took a snapshot of this in
time goes to mi and being deployed again
you're getting rds for example so the
database itself on the on the on
database you can take a start shopping
time and you can restore it to any
number of databases so aws provides you
with amazing tools um
uh basically out of the box you all you
need to do is click i wanna basically a
copy i wanna i wanna create ami i wanna
have a snapshot and all of this is
available and you're gonna find that
creating additional boxes was never
simple more more simple and you quite
like you will never want to go back to
the physical as as i don't tend to do
only if i have to and i don't do this
very often
so
another
slide if we can do
um
evolution of architecture
in additional environments imagine uh
architectural uh decisions are usually
implemented as a static one-time event
during the lifetime of the system
in the cloud
the cloud providers actually
the cloud provides the capacity to
automate and test on demand this lowered
the risk and of design changes and makes
implementation of innovations and new
features easy and actually quick which
means that you are in stuck with the
last year technology you always deploy
the latest ones i had a question where
from because
imi and snapshot works in conjunction
um yes actually does when you think of
ami
ami is a
physical copy or a digital copy you
think of that
of a whole server
what snapshot is it says it's a it's a
copy of the volume or of the hard drive
of this particular server so mi if you
think about it consists of the server
settings and the data so the snapshot
the snapshot itself is just a snap of
the data that you had on the drive
without actually server itself
so
those four those are actually combined
and work together you can take
individual snapshots of the hard drives
if you want because maybe you want to
take a backup of your data and restart
some hours for later but if you're
thinking about the whole server and the
system itself you would quite likely
take my
copy and then you can basically
replicate it not only with an
environment but funny enough you can
copy the same amis across every other
region and you can deploy the same
server that you set up let's say in in
dublin or us in any other place in the
world um and that's as simple as few
clicks and i will be able to show you
this late later on
during the session
sorry i had a quick water just to clear
my throat so i don't squeak
now four pillars of aws
which is well architected framework um
that we're gonna be discussing
first of all
security as i mentioned to you guys
before security is something that aws is
proud of they're actually market leader
their
systems are set up in the way that
everything out of the box can be
potentially encrypted and secured if you
want to it's up to you if you want to
enable this or now majority of the
things are enabled by default but there
are a few things like encryption of the
data at rest for example which means
encrypting the whole hard drive it's
it's optional it doesn't cost you really
anything all you need to do is take a
box when you actually create a server
and that's as simple as this as i
mentioned also before aws has multiple
iso certificates and also they used in
the us for the government to keep all
the data and i know in the uk aws is
used
by a lot of companies including
mi5 for storing particular system
systems so basically by police and
government in uk to achieve the same
thing
additional thing is how reliable the
system is now i'm going to give you a
little bit secret about aws itself when
you think about um
um
i have a question from charanjit um
about is it compliant with hipaa and pci
dss i'm not entirely sure about hipaa
because i didn't go as far as that i
know it's a pci compliant and it's got
all the certifications you can download
all the all the paperwork and everything
from aws to be able to pass the pci and
with your um
with your provider so yes aws is pci
compliant now coming back to how
reliable the aws is a little secret from
inside is if you think about aws and the
cloud what it is and what it's actually
um
build from
aws itself is using extremely extremely
cheap hardware
it's using extremely uh small boxes it
is an extremely um
small um
components and pretty much cheap is the
the name when you think of amazon you
you probably don't know this but
because they're using chip and the
hardware and they're actually using
supermicro across the whole data centers
around every single country in the world
what they do is
they're
providing hundreds and thousands
of
servers
and
because of that they can achieve such a
huge uptime which means every single
time you're actually on one of the boxes
on one of the servers and using the
resource if this bucket box is having
any issue they might switch you straight
away to another box uh by simply just
restarting your your server which means
you will have issues and i can tell you
this for sure um
we were running systems above 10 000 uh
servers in the cloud uh 15 000 sometimes
and on the daily basis we had one or two
going down and that's absolutely normal
every single hardware
in the world will eventually fail i know
you might have a service in iraq that
running maybe for 10 years straight and
it's amazing number and and it it's
possible to achieve but when you think
of a cloud don't think that they're
using state of art most expensive
hardware because it's it's not true
otherwise they would charge you so much
you wouldn't be able to pay for it the
whole video about the cloud and how
reliable it is is that they have
hundreds of thousands of server and they
have not a single point of failure which
means if a single hydra fails they don't
care they have a hundred thousands in
the rug next to it and your data is
replicated across pretty much three or
four data centers in the same time which
means your data is always available this
is what they give you
now
um i have
another question from
rabi babu if i want to communication
across other than aws bpc prem
in this case how security is going to be
um i will discuss this with you once we
actually reach the
vpc and then we'll exactly discuss this
uh which will
be probably today so i'm gonna be able
to answer this question mention this
before uh after and i will
second and third thing sorry performance
efficiency now
it's up to you how you're to use the
cloud you have full control of the cloud
you can utilize you can with a single
button
with a single click of the button you
can deploy 100 servers 1000 servers even
even if you want if if your wallet can
handle that
or if your boss will pay for it
obviously
but
it's up to you you can scale it down to
bare minimum just to make system running
and then when you have a sale you can
bump it to maybe 20 just to make sure
you run and that's exactly what
performance efficiency is now
the last one
uh cost optimization it's actually what
we just mentioned cost optimization is
up to you how you're going to utilize
that amazon gives you all the tools
including the advisory tool that we
discussed yesterday that you can see
what servers are underperforming what
are overperforming maybe where to save
some money and and for once you'll be
able to have dynamic uh bill it's not
that fixed but like from the data center
that you keep paying the same amount of
money every month and whatever you use
you know or you don't use you still
paying for it because it sits there and
takes space and most of the time it
actually heats up the air rather than
doing anything really in this case
you'll be able to fully scale up and
down and make sure the cost is always
the most efficient appropriate towards
the system as i mentioned before to you
guys
um we we managed to replace two or three
servers in a simple simple uh simple
task with um
with lambda and instead of paying 1500 a
month we actually managed to shrink it
down to as i mentioned yesterday 0.05
us sent which means it is efficient and
it still does the same task so it's
exactly what we're talking here about
so we're going to skip to the next
slide
security
now
apply security to all layers and
security should be
thorough for example instead of
firewalls at the edge of the
infrastructure use firewalls in other
security controls of all the resources
another example of this
is using security in the ec2 now
aws itself gives you
really
really good out-of-the-box security it's
up to you how you're going to use it but
it it's it's it's out there
they give you option to trace
all the security uh features and
settings you have as well as trace all
the logs
they give you automated responses to
security events for example you have an
access on specific port or someone open
specific port what can happen is email
can be generated saying hey actually
someone opened a port on the system that
is in production and
you know do you want to do something
about it which means it is fully
automated you can focus on securing your
system what it means is
instead of um you trying to guess what
what's wrong you can actually secure it
out of the box everything and because
the principle behind aws is everything
is locked and then you're unlocking
specific layers so when you deploy a new
server in aws all the ports by default
are locked and secure all you need to do
is start opening the port so it's not
like an open firewall straight to the
internet and then you have a problem
and also you have best uh security
practices which are fully automated um
which uh one of the things is exactly
the
um advisory tool so the uh the one that
we discussed that will
show you which ports are open maybe
maybe it will flag that force 22 is open
to the internet and maybe didn't know
about it and i actually have industry
standards uh latest reviewed um
uh principles and policies regarding all
those different things
um
i have a question here came from autism
is there performance is there a
performance cost when encrypting a hard
drive uh itself now it's a very good
question
aws
states that there is no
virtually no performance itself and
that's pretty much what they will tell
you i can tell you like this when you
enable encryption and that's a little
secret from within aws
they're running actually two different
networks within one is unencrypted and
other one is encrypted and those two
networks
are working fully independently they use
different switches they use different
layers and in fact they're using totally
different topologies itself when you
encrypt your data it will go over the
encrypted network instead of the open
one and up until pretty much 2015-16
uh not many people were using all those
encryption uh features they basically
didn't know how to use it and the
security network a secured network was
really empty nobody was using it which
means if you actually enable security on
all your hard drives for example it was
much quicker sometimes to go over this
secure network because it was
underutilized the other normal one so at
this current stage there is maybe one
percent maybe two uh degradation of
performance but you probably will never
notice it and it's fully uh managed by
aws when you use encryption of the
volume you quite like we use a service
from aws called kms which is exactly to
manage your keys and everything is
hardware um
encrypted they have special um devices
that decrypt data between
ebs for example in this case hard drive
and the and and the server and
everything is hardware they decrypted
and encrypted so it's actually very very
quick
so i hope i answered your question this
way
so
aws traders responsibility model this is
very very important and i really want
you to to to understand the particular
slide
because that's one of the most
fundamental slides you can actually have
what aws mentions or just let me remove
my doodles
what aws mentions and is trying to
always make it clear
is aws is only responsible for that
particular bit what does it mean they're
responsible for compute they're
responsible for stories responsible for
a database and networking also they're
responsible for all the data centers
around the world which means it is their
responsibility
of every single hardware bit you can
think of
everything that is on top of that which
we're gonna discuss now
like even your encryption
uh basically a network
how how you're gonna enable encryption
and integrity
os network and firewall configuration
platform application identity and access
and the most important customized data
everything beyond that point
it's your responsibility
aws provides you with the hardware with
all those features all the control
panels and everything else you want but
what sits on top of the box it is your
problem aws doesn't have access to any
of your data and i have to stress this
they do not have ever access to any of
your hard drives they don't have access
to any of your servers they can
restart your server that that's fine but
they don't actually have any
access to anything ever and this is done
on purpose to make sure that they are
compliant with lots of regulations um
and to make sure that
the data or anything else cannot be
stolen or leaked out by their own staff
or anything else
and that's the biggest
point that i'm trying to make here um
that aws is unresponsible for hardware i
have a question
from
ashok uh
whose responsibility is to update the
security patches on the os that's
actually a very good question now i can
answer this in a simple way
there are pretty much two
different scenarios you're gonna have
scenario number one you have
an easy
ec2 box yeah and you're running actually
on easy to box and maybe windows or
linux or anything else you want now the
box itself so all the hardware and
everything else
belongs to aws they're just ranking to
you
but os itself all the data and all the
networking security or whatever you're
implementing are implemented on it
belongs to you which means you are
physically responsible to manage your
own
security
in which case uh you need to patch the
systems you need to update them you need
to pretty much implement anything you
want you can actually
on aws website there is a
security builder team that actually is
very very updated because aws is very
proud um of of their security worldwide
and the kind of leaders at this current
stage if there is any problem like a
ghost show or any other
issue security threat that you can hear
about this on the tv they are pretty
much one of the first ones to to to
implement um all the fixes regarding how
to do it help you to do it they're
they're kind of practically trying for
you to do it but they will not do it for
you and that's the biggest advantage now
the second scenario is service let's say
called rds r d s now the rds is a fully
managed service which means that
everything on it which means a hardware
that means an os and that means even the
database engine itself is managed by aws
what it means
it is fully managed and maintained and
updated
patched and everything else you can
think of by aws itself all you need to
do is specify the maintenance window
when they're allowed to do that
and within this maintenance window uh
the box will actually go through the
patching and all this stuff which is
great because suddenly you're not
responsible for any of that which is
which is amazing because you don't have
to spend days
doing the same task over and over again
just picking update update update and
make sure you do it correctly plus i
know for sure none of you guys no matter
how many years or centuries you work in
it you cannot know about every single
security issue
the whole teams and the whole whole
company is dedicated to this and they
still
they don't know it all so i i would say
the rds and manage services from aws are
actually pretty awesome because they
take headache away from you when it
comes to
updating all of that all you need to do
is worry about the data that sits on top
of that and that's all it is which is
great and you're only paying for for for
this privilege so that's that's that's
the advantage
um
i have asked i have a question from
chandra is it i ask and pass services
are they um
are they
i presume are they kind of shared
responsibility as well in in this
context is this correct
for those who actually don't know i ask
itself it's infrastructure as a service
and pass itself as a platform as a
service you can actually think of aws as
a infrastructure as a service and pass
as a platform you can think of rds
because actually platform which means it
is platform as a service provided to you
which means all you need to do is just
upload your data and use it so um
i mean do we have ios and pass service
in lbs yes
yes we do as i mentioned uh chandra the
ios itself is is
is amazon if you think about it because
they provide you infrastructure as a
service you don't ever have to go to the
rock or anywhere else and fill it with
the hard drives in fact you cannot so
all the hardware all the all the
networking everything else is provided
by them so virtually aws is is now
regarding pass you can build your own if
you want on top of the the um aws itself
but they provide different services like
ids like um
like
s3 for example
which is actually a pass because it is
dedicated platform as a service to
provide specific uh tasks which i hope i
explained the question
uh correctly so that is very important
and aws always stresses this out that
the shared responsibility all the way to
the hardware is them anything on top of
that it is your responsibility
so moving to the next uh slide security
in the cloud
um i have another question from
charanjit
if we run instance in ec2
i means is it our responsibility to
patch os and hardening its security
that's absolutely correct ec2 is nothing
else as a vm and they give you the
hardware they give you the
cpu and memory you want anything on top
of that it's your responsibility which
means they pretty much give you empty
box and all you need to do is basically
take care of os take care of
applications and everything that sits on
top of that
so yes you need to take care of all of
that
so security in the cloud
what we need to discuss is
data protection
privilege management
um infrastructure protection and
let me just close this one sorry for a
second
and detective controls now
data protection itself it's up to the
user you need to make sure that your
systems are protected and the data is
secure now database will give you all
the networking all the hardware but it's
entirely up to you if you're gonna
secure it or not if you're gonna make
your servers publicly available aws will
not be responsible if someone actually
goes over your ssh because you open that
and breaks into your system now they do
have a tools in place and security uh in
place to actually be able to detect
specific threads and maybe block that
they don't mention really that much
because they don't want you to know it
but aws itself is is really really
protected um second thing we have is a
privilege management it's entirely up to
you who you're gonna grant access to you
can have multiple users in your
environment we're gonna discuss a little
bit later and
it's entirely up to you what kind of
privileges you give to them if you give
them too many people just like i'm gonna
make you a full admin just because it's
easy to do and then they for some reason
delete uh some servers because they have
a right to do so well it's your fault
not aws infrastructure protection um
they give you ability to protect all of
this with the devices like mfa which is
a multiple factor authentication which
you can have on the mobile phone or you
can have a little phone um or token and
you can enable this it's not enabled by
default they can enable this on every
single user account which means whenever
they log into the console they will need
to not only provide the user and the
password but also they need to generate
a new pin every time or a new token on
your code and this code is only valid
for let's say 60 seconds which means
after 60 seconds they have to do it
again if they didn't manage which means
it's extremely secure because even
though some users will for example send
email with their username and password
and this email my might be i don't know
intercept it or someone might you know
steal it from your desktop or you have
maybe virus that actually went through
all your files and made it public public
which happens a lot
it's up to you that you can then set up
mfa and
even though someone does have a user in
the password well without mfi they're
not gonna go far because they must
provide this to be able to access aws
which i would highly encourage you to do
because it's probably one of the first
things you want to do
and one of the last things on the list
here
let me just slide this window
is detective controls
now aws does give you different kind of
controls it allows you to log everything
into into a cloud trail as we discussed
yesterday it allows you to pretty much
have all the
view of what's going on within your
systems and it's actually great now
they're not going to do much about it
they're not going to tell you hey you
have a bridge because it's integrated to
you if you open too much security on
your systems what they will give you is
ability to log it and maybe parse it
somehow and and link it with some
applications that will actually uh flag
it maybe via email maybe on your screen
that there is a strange activity and
that's exactly what they what they give
you
so let me hide this
thing
and let's skip straight to the next one
data protection
so
before
architecting any systems use the
following practices to ensure security
of the aws
account
you need to first of all categorize data
based on sensitivity it is very
important you might have a systems that
um consists of a web server you might
have a system that consists of of a
database and maybe there is some sort of
application and backend system that is
running there obviously web servers
quite likely will be exposed to the
internet and that's the primary use for
them now the database itself will not
and that's a different tier and
you need to make sure that you
understand and you actually draw it so
for example you have non-sensitive data
here and that
is
exposed to the internet
and behind that you have a database
and then you have additional layer if
you want and you have a application
server that actually does some sort of
magical operations on the database and
generate generates reports
and that particular layer here
is exposed to the internet but that one
here is not which means it cannot be
accessed directly from the internet but
you can then access different um rules
that will allow those boxes just and
those boxes connect to the database but
nothing else which means the internet
cannot access any of your systems which
is actually great and the same applies
to the backend box here
because there are multiple tiers and and
levels that you can set up later on with
security groups and and different
permissions you'll be able to do it
without any problem
um
i have a question from ravi babu
regarding by default user has all these
authentications um yes every single user
and i'm gonna show you this again later
when we're gonna be doing hands-on we'll
have access to all those security that
we just mentioned it's not enabled you
have to take the box and you need to set
up your mfa device either token or a
software one and but it is not enabled
and aws does give you all those features
and entirely up to you and it's your
responsibility to actually make it
happen
last thing on this podcast slide is a
grand least privilege as i mentioned
before i've seen this multiple times and
quite likely i will always see it in the
future what people do when they start
with aws
is their ground permissions and usually
when they grant permissions themselves
they ground pretty much for admin
because it's either any other one is too
restrictive which
throws you lots of errors doesn't allow
you to do many things so to make your
life easier lots of people do that and
then the new person starts and you give
them the same permissions just because
it's easy now it's entirely up to you
how you're gonna do this i would advise
you to grant at least amount of
privilege to every single person
especially when they never work with aws
i've seen this so many times someone
tried to
uh delete one environment uh or one
server for an environment and what
they've done is treated the whole
environment in production by mistake
because they didn't understand how this
works and the whole system went down and
obviously you can blame the person to do
that but it was actually
your own fault that you got that much
permission
and and you didn't make sure that
they're they're aware of what they what
they're doing i i've even seen a lot of
um very very advanced system
administrators and cloud guys after
working whole day of like 12 hours let's
say you're extremely tired you don't
even know your name and then you're
responsible for maybe deploying
something new or or deleting something
old and because you're tired you have no
idea what time it is you just basically
click on random stuff without thinking
and you just drop the whole environment
and even to yourself you can grant
different levels of of of privileges you
can for example restrict yourself from
production that you can do only maybe
read so you can see it but you cannot
touch it and that means that in the
future if you ever make a mistake well
mistake will not go through because of
your own permissions are restricted
which is actually a great idea and it
makes the whole system much more stable
because you're not gonna drop the whole
production environment just like that
so data protection
in the data protection itself we have
multiple different uh tiers as i
mentioned this before we have encrypt
and manage data and uh services like i
am or kms today we'll be talking quite
likely about iom and we will also
mention kms um i think in today's
session i'll need to check that we also
have cloudtrail what cloudtrail is it
it's logging every single action on aws
console and api which means it can be
traced back to an individual or a system
we also have um make use of resilient
storage systems like s3 now that is very
important as i mentioned this before and
i will say this quite likely again aws
s3 has eleven nines of durability what
it means is
if you think about 99.9
percent
that's a lot but actually aws does have
nine nine nine and there are actually
eleven of those behind what it means is
if you store ten thousand object with
aws
um let me just hide this for a second
if you store 10 000 object with aws s3
you can on average expect
sorry
to incur a loss of a single object once
every 10
10 million years that's correct if you
ever upload 10 000 objects aws
is
capable of losing one file
in 10 million yes that's actually
i've never seen such numbers if if
anyone ever
any provider gives you a you know uptime
of of something like a 99 point sorry
99.9
that's that's awesome most of the
production system that i've seen running
actually maybe 98 97
good ones maybe
99 just about but not 99.11 that
actually never happened and they do have
to say this because obviously it's only
hardware but the way they replicate the
stuff across multiple um
data centers is extremely extremely good
and they and and and aws itself is proud
uh that the data protection they have is
such a durable service one of the last
things is also use a versioning of y and
life cycle of s3 which means that you
can enable this by simply clicking on
this and i'm going to show you later on
as well how to do it enable versioning
which means every single file that
overrides the previous one it's kept in
a history it's basically like um like a
git or any other um versioning
tool that allows you to keep all the
files which means in someone visa follow
a mistake or write this with some sort
of a newer version guess what it doesn't
really matter yes the newest version
will be the only one visible to the user
but if you look into the console you can
actually restore any version of the file
before which means you never lose the
file downside of that you have to pay
for all the versions out there because
they are kept as individual files under
the same pretty much name but in the
different version but guess what aws s3
is so cheap that probably you will never
even see s3 on your bill because it's so
so cheap
so let me go to the next slide if okay
privilege management it's a central part
of information security and security
program to ensure only authorized and um
authenticated users
access your
resources in the way that is acceptable
to ensure compliance and use
what it actually means is
is um
you're responsible for granting
privileges to the users if you think
about um aws think of it as pretty much
active directory um
when inactive director you have a user
and create a new one you can grant them
pretty much all admin rights if you want
to if you if
if you really really that
um that that crazy and and you know and
you want them to do pretty much
everything including maybe even deleting
the active directory server itself
because that's what admin can do but
most of the time when you work for
bigger companies everyone is restricted
to a bare minimum
amount of permissions and it's up to the
user
like uh like an admin or or system you
know anyone wants this id to make sure
that people cannot go beyond and above
maybe you have some regulations in the
company saying you know what we have
users that should not be able to access
this resource because they're not uh
cleared maybe there is some sort of
secret data on on your systems like
maybe uh
good idea is um maybe working for
financial firm and they have a data on
the on the on the on the system that if
leaked could actually
lead to
a
huge financial
instability on the market and you don't
want everyone to just access this and
there's this very famous case of of mr
snowden as you probably know so the
whistleblower from us that took lots of
secret documents around the world and
basically made it make it made it public
and you think about it well yes he did a
bad thing from one side but lots of
people think he did the good stuff a
good thing and i'm not gonna really
choose a side of this kind of stage
because it's not my place to do so but
you can prevent this kind of behavior by
applying proper privileges and making
sure that people have only the right
they they they need and if they need new
rights because they want to go a little
bit beyond and evolve at least they need
to ask for it someone like you or
someone else in your company and it can
be reviewed and for example if someone
asks hey can i have access to all your
files and all the s3 on all the buckets
the first question should be why do you
need that
um what are you trying to do and you
know maybe they need only access to one
bucket but they don't know they just
want access to everything and it's very
good so
i would highly i would highly encourage
you all guys
to make sure you review the privileged
privileges of all the users always very
very close and make sure that
nobody is using more than they really
need
um we can use in here a few things we
can use uh access control disk for that
um which is also known as acl and i'm
gonna
show you this uh later we can use the
role-based access controls as well as
passport management and i'm going to
discuss this in detail in the next few
slides hopefully today
so
infrastructure protection
basically to me the best practices and
industry or maybe regulations that you
have in your country or your company uh
using multiple layers of defense and a
multi-part authentication um in all the
types of environment is sometimes a must
and usually when you work for a big
company they do have a multiple tiers of
security they will have a front-facing
firewall they will have uh mid-facing
firewalls between the the internet and
the the gray zone or like uh
[Music]
dmz then they will have internal
firewalls for different systems between
the file file servers and and different
things and all of those different tiers
can be pretty much replicated on on the
aws infrastructure itself
so
mfa is one of those things that allows
you to authenticate with additional
protection but uh also
sorry for that
but also you can
implement vpc that we discussed before
which is your private virtual private uh
um container which actually only
specific systems within will be able to
talk to each other anything from outside
unless you really want that cannot
communicate with this in any way and
also you have additional tools like
cloud trail and cloud watch that
actually log monitor and alert if any of
that particular behavior happens so you
aws gives you all the tools and all the
settings you you you can you really want
to use and it's up to you how you're
going to use them so that's that's the
biggest advantage
um next one
detective controls
um i see
a
question from umesh
regarding what is stateful and what is
stateless
uh
it's a very good question and we
actually gonna discuss this exactly when
we will be talking about a
in the previous slide sorry in the
previous slide when we're gonna be
talking about uh
types of security we have we have
security groups and we have an uh
knuckles so called one is stateless and
one is stateful and we're gonna say
exactly why we call them like that and
when we use both so i will come back to
you on that when we're gonna be
discussing this in a great detail later
so
we have detective controls
in here we have um you can use detective
controls to detect or identify
anything potential security bridge or
both maybe for quality support process
or compliance
reasons
and a few of the detective controls are
and aws cloud trail which is a web best
web-based service um
let me skip sorry yes here
let me just select that
we have aws
cloud trail which allows you to log all
the api calls of every single activity
in a whole entire account yes cloud 3
itself need to enable for every single
region separate because it's logged into
the s3 bucket from where you can take
those logs and you can then parse and
process them whichever way you want but
it allows you to actually uh log a whole
entire um
environment with pretty much a single
click and it will start um creating
those logs and populating them if there
is any activity
second one is a cloud watch cloud which
monitors the aws resources as we
discussed yesterday like
hard drives network activity databases
and volumes and it'll actually give you
starts now it is not used to
to to create logs but what it can do
is give you charts and potential issues
like let's say you have a system that is
running hard because you have a sale
cloud which itself can actually be used
to generate maybe a alert if any of your
systems go beyond 80 of cpu or maybe if
the if the network activity spikes for
some reason it will be able to alert you
about that which is actually very very
good next one is find about
configurations and changes in
infrastructure so-called aws config what
it is is if you deploy environment
something like a production grade
environment what you'll be able to do
you will be able to
um pretty much save this in a in a in
in
and if any change in the future occurs
because someone looked down and changed
maybe a single security group or someone
added maybe additional server that maybe
or maybe someone removed the server
you basically be straight away and
notified about that and it's
exactly great because you can make sure
the environment be deployed is exactly
what you agreed maybe you have some sort
of documentation of it and obviously the
last thing you want to do is someone to
log in and start changing stuff while
you actually agreed through multiple
cards or any other process in your
company that this is exactly what it is
also you can make sure that the system
you're running is exactly the same as
system that is for example qa so quality
assurance that um when
guys are testing the the systems direct
testing exactly the same
infrastructure and the same setup and
it's actually used for that another
thing is aws s3 and it can record all
the details of access requests what you
can do is there's a little tick box
basically log over activity on s3 which
means every single file from every
single bucket can
always be logged as someone read it
someone change it someone someone
updated it or any other action which is
great because suddenly you have a
control of actually auditing what people
within your company are doing which
which most of the time you have no idea
imagine you have a windows box uh which
acts as a web server a sorry not web
server a file server and people
accessing it people are you know uh
using it yes you can enable additional
vlogging on it and trust me it is a
nightmare i've been there i've done that
it
it's not pretty and it's difficult to do
and what you do here is you tick the box
and the whole job is done it actually
locks all the activity
um
let me just minimize this particular
thing sorry for that
now one of the last features of detected
controls is that you can use a fault
lock feature to preserve critical data
in the class here what it means is
imagine you have
recently i actually worked for the for
the financial company and i was
responsible to do a
a
storage system for all
of their uh trading and all of the
information pretty much every single
activity within the whole organization
and organization was pretty big they had
over 50 000 people worldwide
now because of the regulation states
that they must keep their all activity
in a safe place that cannot be changed
um to meet this regulation they had a
huge huge iraq full of basically storage
devices that were basically logging off
this from entire world in a single place
in the in in in uk
and they have to keep it and
funny enough they have to keep it for
seven years and also they need to make
sure that no data is actually changed
updated or removed for up to seven years
and that's a regulation if they don't
have this
they will have lots of problems and the
problem was that this particular system
they were using the old-fashioned system
was actually failing and it was so old
that
they had an issue and they had to comply
with lots of regulations what it means
is we actually deployed a new solution
based on a lambda
and what we introduced is so called
above a vault lock which means we
created the simple policy saying you can
upload stuff here that's fine but you
cannot delete anything for up to seven
years which means every single object or
a file in this case that was ever uh
uploaded to to the the glasser itself
had a policy saying you know what this
podca file will not ever
and by ever i mean 70 years
be removed changed or modified in any
way even if you try you can't this file
will be persistent for seven years yes
obviously if you delete the whole
account uh like terminate the whole head
of this account the data will be erased
to get me wrong yes but for as long as
you're paying for that account that
particular policy works which means it's
it's a compliance
so um
so that there you go
we can skip to the next slide
uh regarding uh
lobby
ability
so in here
amazon defines reliability as ability of
the system to recover from
infrastructures or service failures
dynamically acquire competing resources
to meet demand and mitigate disruptions
such as misconfiguration and
transient network issues
what it means i mentioned to you guys
before and i will quite likely say it a
few more times we all know that aws
works on many many hundreds of thousand
servers and they quite likely not the
best
the reason why they can achieve such a
huge
uptimes is because they do not keep data
in one place they keep it replicated
across multiple systems in the same time
in multiple data centers and this is how
it well it works and i noticed that
really with aws itself
once you actually have data there
there's quite likely no need for you to
back it up because once you actually put
data in s3 if you use a single file out
of 10 000 files to upload it every 10
million years guess what that's good
enough to me i've seen i've seen
magnetic tapes of the backup systems
going really bad after after a week or
two because someone kept them next to
the heater or maybe they were in the
dump and you cannot read them and what
kind of backup is it if the tape itself
cannot be restored because it was in the
in a little bit humid environment and
it's not working and with aws
you can make sure that all your files um
will be pretty much um accessible
whenever you need
so pretty much that's that's from uh
um
that's from the from from this
particular section
so
also regarding the
[Music]
the subject you can test recovery
procedures which means if you ever
upload anything to aws and you want to
recover it guess what you can you don't
need to run for any tapes you don't need
to bring lots of different hard drives
you actually can recover everything you
uploaded by basically downloading it
again and making sure uh the the data is
intact and in fact there are sometimes
regulations setting them once a year for
example you must test random files and
they give you let's say 20 different
files from my phone badge
that you must download open and make
make sure it's not corrupted and i can
show you we've done this multiple times
consider up in an automated fashion and
and it's very very good
another one automatically recover from
failure
what it means is when you for example
have ec2 instance and ec2 instance
failed
um
went dead
what it means is aws straight away
straightaway will give you ability or
automatically launch another instance
and take the data from a faulty instance
which wasn't really sitting here it was
sitting on the network drive anyway and
adapted to this one which means you can
just basically restart the faulty one or
put up the new one and the server will
be exactly in the way that the previous
one stopped guess what try to do this in
the normal on-prem with the hardware if
possible well you can't if you haven't
worked with the vmware you pretty much
know what i'm talking about
because you cannot kind of achieve the
same thing you can have a vm a
single vm and for example you can use
iscsi
and attach drive and if this server
fails you can basically create a
duplicate of that and attach the iscsi
to the new box and you off you go
it's pretty much the same in aws with
the exception of uh it's much more
simpler than um than vmware itself
it's it's basically in most cases you
can enable self healing or auto recovery
as well and it will happen behind the
scene automatically all
probably you will notice is the box will
restart which most of the time is not a
big problem especially when you have a
multiple boxes in a system designed to
wear for um
you know full uptime and at least have
two boxes in production to make sure
that in case one goes down either one
can take over and and both of them are
working fine
another
another point is you can scale
horizontally to increase
availability and that's important point
imagine
i'm gonna remove that and i'm gonna draw
here imagine you have e
elb here and you have internet on top
traffic comes to eob that's on its own
it's almost a bulletproof solution it's
a fully monitored service that is a load
balancer in front and then you have a
two or maybe three boxes just for fun
because
and the traffic close to all three boxes
no that's great but imagine
suddenly someone
comes to you and says hey actually you
know what we are going to double the
amount of traffic we're going to have to
always those boxes because there's a
sale or maybe because we have more
customers or maybe because we've done
some marketing
um
you know a mail that everyone now will
be coming guess what what you can do is
to take copy of this particular box add
additional ones
and basically ask eob to start serving
the traffic and what we call it is
horizontal
because you can have almost in almost
um unlimited number of boxes behind alb
um and you scale uh horizontally rather
than vertically which is exactly what
you're trying to do and it's actually a
very very good solution and it's one of
the most common cases that you always
use on aws
um and aws was actually designed for
that so it's exactly what we're trying
to do
one of the last things on this
particular slide is stop casing capacity
exactly what we mentioned you don't need
to guess it you deploy two boxes
and if it's not enough you deploy a
third one it is too much you delete and
basically you always keep which means
you don't need to um over provision you
don't need to uh order more hardware
than you need and then the hardware sits
on the shelf and it's not used um
because most of the time when you have a
servers or anything like this on your on
your rack shelf or anywhere else you
most of the time will overprovision this
on purpose just because you want to have
more capacity that you you need but in
this case you only provision whatever
you need and if you need go further you
go beyond if you need to go below you
scale down and that's the benefit of aws
itself
um
i have a few questions here
when you when we refer to that instance
is it an ec2 instance or s3 instance
okay that's a very very good question
on car i'm gonna explain like this
ec2 instance is like a server and
potentially
it's like um if you ever worked with a
vmware it's basically like a vm
itself so it's it's it's it's
it's allocated amount of hardware on
on
on the bigger box that is given to you
for you to use and
we only say at that instance in case of
ec2 because s3 doesn't have instances s3
is a service that you basically upload
all your files and that's the biggest
difference
um so i hope i answered this question
to you
another question from tranjit
which one is uh sorry which one are
iscsi and sun storage in aws
now to be honest um
aws doesn't provide any information
about the infrastructure as i said this
before
even the people that work on in aws and
i know quite a few of them do not know
what aws consists of it's actually a
secret it's a guided secret that
if uh everyone would know probably they
wouldn't like aws as much but because
how aws is is is built and the way it's
built
and and it because it's a secret
everyone thinks is amazing cloud which
it is but behind all of this not just
normal servers like you would have on
your shelf behind all of this is normal
networking equipment that you would have
in your office i wouldn't really go as
far as unmanaged switches and all of
this with maybe like crappy cables no i
would go far away from that they still
use state-of-the-art networking and
cabling all of that just to make sure
that it's extremely stable
but
it is
a secret i can tell you that
uh eps for example volume that you can
attach so it's a kind of network drive
um that you're attaching to your to your
instance um i presume it's a ice casting
but don't take my
my comment as as a stable answer because
we're only guessing
it acts like a ice gazi it behaves like
gaskazi the the network traffic and
everything else and also uh block level
stores that we have it acts like a
scuzzy rather than
a sound because uh we can take this
instance and move it somewhere else and
you can re-attach it and it's easy so it
kind of behaves like a ice casing more
or less
now we are in aws itself and uh i'm
gonna be showing you all of that more
and more as we go along and what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna go to services i'm
gonna go to ec2
the compute
and in here i'm going to show you the
image you can read about this and a lot
on the aws by default aws will give you
limit of 20 servers
for any any any type and obviously the
bigger the boxes less they want you to
have now it's not a fixed limit you can
always increase
a and you know
increase if you want to and
you can virtually there is physically no
limit to how many bucks you can have i
know environment that we're running
around 15 000 servers in in in a one a
single account which which is great
because you know it's a massive
environment
but um i noticed that maybe it's easier
sometimes to split your
whole environment between multiple
accounts for redundancy or or for any
other reason and i will be able to give
you some examples in the future about
that as well which are actually valid so
physically there's no limit but you will
need to ask aws whether
by the ticket or request hey i need my
uh maybe x a c one extra large instance
to be increased from 20 to something
like 50 because we have a sale and we
need more of those and aws will come
back to you within a matter of minutes
and say there you go go for it
all they do is basically validate that
you are not some sort of uh adidas uh
hacker that is trying to basically spin
up hundreds of thousands of instances
and attack a new website and this is how
they defend against that you physically
need to send a reasonable increase if
you for example will go to them and say
hey from 20 can i have 20 000 they're
gonna say actually no because we don't
have a history of your account and we
don't really know what it is so when you
have a new account maybe the increase
from 20 to 50 is reasonable anything
beyond maybe 100 they will ask
additional questions which exactly
is um is the point of this whole thing
uh so i hope i i answered your question
um
i have another question how much
instances we can run in ec2 uh is there
a limit of ratings
on easy so i i hope i already explained
that eventually there's no limit on that
count there is a soft limit so-called
that you can increase at any given time
so coming back to the presentation
itself
so let's
uh another question from uh gabriel
will it automatically spin up more
instances based on the traffic detected
by elb or should we specify it
now you'll be by itself will not add any
extra instances all it does it roots the
traffic that comes in between all the
boxes or all the instances that you're
currently running behind it
if you wanna auto
auto add more instances you will use a
service called
auto scaling in conjunction with eob
itself and i will discuss this with you
exactly later what it means you will
specify a minimum and a max amount of
servers and specific thresholds let's
say if the load goes beyond 60
add two extra boxes or if the load goes
beyond below let's say
of cpu then remove the boxes but always
keep a minimum amount of boxes of let's
say three which is exactly what you're
trying to achieve and that will allow
you to do automatically going up and
down and not only will save money by
that but also you can guarantee that
human free interaction can actually spin
up and down environment just to
accommodate the traffic
uh
i have another question from autism will
we see more of the aws uh like uh
like you or a
for hans on training i will i will be
more than happy and i really want to
show you as much as possible from aws
console and how to do lots of things
which in my opinion actually gives you
the best results because we need to
understand all of this and and obviously
that's that's a kind of a little bit of
dry knowledge we're trying to pass right
now but i'm giving you all those
examples from a real life and i really
hope that
all of those examples you can imagine
how more or less it works and you get
better understanding and quicker
understanding of actually um how
specific concepts are are working so i
would say i will give you much more
hands-on
as well as we go
along so let me skip to the next
slide
basically
how reliable is the cloud
we can actually say
that the foundations change management
and failure management
foundations are the old operations that
you can do
that
will make your application stable and
from aws perspective all the foundations
is that they provide your hardware and
redundancy in any way possible so
all your
systems that you're currently running
are as
maximized for a full uptime
change management is entirely up to you
you deploy your application you deploy
all the all the changes and it's
entirely up to you how you're gonna do
it now aws um does give you um a little
bit of a
head start on that you can create um
mmis of your instances which means the
copies and you can change that and you
can redeploy from the new one so you
have exactly the same change management
and also they give you
um
ability to restrict uh
by that provider permissions users that
are performing certain changes and
that's the change management really and
then finally management is they give you
all the tools and like cloud watch for
example or or or um
a cloud trail that you can actually see
whenever something failed or is about to
fail or maybe something did fail and
then you can go back into logs and and
see
what exactly happened and you can
investigate that um you can communicate
with aws very very well you can use
their support it's uh it's very good i
actually worked with aws for for
seven years now and i worked closely
with aws teams um their their knowledge
is extremely good i can assure you of
that if you have a problem quite likely
they had it before and they will point
you towards the right direction they
will give you all the documentation you
need they will actually explain a little
bit what they will not do and that's
important to remember
is that they will not do stuff for you
despite the fact aws is a managed
service uh as a whole platform
everything that sits on top as we
discussed before it's your
responsibility so they will give you a
really good articles and point you to to
maybe um
a forums or or articles that explain how
to fix this big issue but they will not
do it for you
um i have another question from john
andrew sebastian if the load which is
above threshold and if we set out auto
scaling for instances i will learn how
new uh
instances are
removed and added uh yes
the service that we discussed before uh
called autoscaling fully integrates with
eob which means if it says i need more
instances because there is a spike of
traffic it will spin up those instances
basically will provision them for you it
will add make sure that they are up and
running and it will join automatically
eob pool now what you will do
is you you set up so called health
checks which means
if for example
every few seconds uh the the the machine
itself sorry the elb will try to ping
this box and try to access specific link
if it cannot access specific link that
means the box is not ready up until the
stage it can once it can it will add it
correctly and then start serving the
traffic automatically to this particular
box which is exactly the behavior the
same applies when the box actually goes
down and something actually application
maybe stopped working something uh i
don't know a
software may be hydrated from outer
space and the whole system just went
down what will happen is auto scaling
itself via the health check will detect
oh actually i can't access this box and
it will stop serving traffic to the box
instantly and it will show you that
there's a failure what it means it will
not remove this box from from um
from um
from a pool but what it will do it will
not serve any new traffickings and kind
of to you what you want to do maybe you
want to jump on the box and maybe you
want to find what was the problem which
is you know which is entirely fine but
uh auto screen can be set up in the way
that if the failure is detected it
remove the faulty box and it will
replace the box with a new one to start
serving traffic so such options are
available so i hope i answered your
question
um
okay i have a follow-up question from
charlemage which is uh how we determine
the new instances and how do we get ips
host names
now
it's a it's a very good and bad question
uh when you think of a cloud um we don't
really think of a static ap anymore we
don't think about um we can think of
host names but we don't tend to the
reason is
and when using auto scaling itself the
load balancer doesn't care what what's
the ip of the of the box itself uh it's
actually integrated within um it
integrates with the ec2 itself and
basically by the api it joins this
particular um
instance into the pool of eob so you
don't need to set up anything you're
going to get the ips most of the time in
fact 99 of the time all our systems that
i ever run are on the dynamic ipvs
nobody cares what the ip is because if
the box goes down the new one will come
over and join the pool so you don't care
about either ips or hostnames everything
is uh integrated within the system i
hope i answer and i will be able to give
you more examples of that in the future
when we're gonna be discussing exactly
this uh behavior
let me skip to the next one
um
foundations
so before we are getting all the systems
foundations that impact
how stable and reliable system is must
be in place so
important things sufficient oh my
goodness what a big block we have
let me remove that i'm not sure why it's
changing but
hopefully we'll make it nicer sufficient
bandwidth
that's the important bit
sufficient bandwidth itself
is important
now easy to
um
assistance
uh and boxes can
uh have different amount of bandwidth
available imagine if you buy extremely
small box and i can show you the the the
this on the
on here if you're gonna type in google
aws
instance types
one of the nice websites that i i use
pretty much all the time it's funny
enough not the aws one is easy to
instance dot info
i'm gonna show you how it works
now you have multiple
uh instances and all of that is pretty
much live
which means
you can see different types you can see
how much memory you have how many cpu
basically how many units uh storage and
all this as well as network performance
so imagine i'm gonna take a lot of them
just because i can and i'm gonna choose
something like a t2 nano
this particular one i'll highlight this
for you guys let me just do this this
particular one gives you network
performance low wow this doesn't define
really what it is is it like 10 megabits
is it 100 megabits um oh sorry increase
the font size yep can do sorry for that
um
i hope that's big enough
so the instance oh sorry for that
there you go drawing two the instance
that we're talking about has to nano has
a low performance well it costs a little
because it's really really cheap in fact
if you spin out this on your environment
quite likely for free because amazon
gives you this free tier
um and what it means they do not specify
how much network bandwidth it is
they say hello we we kind of know that
low is around maybe between 10 and 20
megabits per second
but it can vary it's it's a it's a cloud
environment it's a short environment
sometimes you'll get 20 sometimes you'll
get 10 and
and it doesn't really say how much now
if you're gonna go for anything bigger
than that so if i'm gonna go for maybe m
for large suddenly we jump to a moderate
what it means um is that we have much
more bangladesh for sure but they still
don't tell you how much um and
we we know that the bandwidth will know
will not go below below certain numbers
and obviously bigger the box you will
get so imagine maybe something like m4
extra whatever
16 it will give you 20 gigabits of
bandwidth now they do tell you that
because they want to make sure you
understand and
sometimes when i'm going to go back to
the course
let me just quickly click
so what sometimes when you're deploying
the different applications make sure
that cpu is not not the only thing that
you're looking at because you'll be
surprised that sometimes you might
saturate the whole uh system because you
are actually pushing all the traffic by
a very small trunk especially on the
network that that we we don't really
know
another one is sufficient compute
capacity which means basically a cpu and
other things i can
go back to my
chart here and i'll be able to show you
we know as
as a fact that uh capacity uh probably
means uh ecu or cpu
as well as the memory itself uh every
single instance will have a different
kind of types which means no matter what
instance you would choose uh you can
accommodate exactly what you're looking
for um
so make sure you always understand how
much resources you need as well as
obviously over the time
what is ecu we have a question from
chandra that's actually very good
question what ecu is is an elastic
compute unit and think of it like that
aws specified
that a single
sorry
aw specified that a single ecu unit
is worth more or less one gigahertz of
compute power
now what it means is that for example if
we have a box something like a
um
i'm gonna do some small one on purpose
uh it's first of all so it's not
invisible let's say we have a box
something like eight units that means
that eight units times uh one gigahertz
more or less will give you performance
of around eight gigahertz performance
now if you think about having a maybe
like an intel core
uh xeon personal server that is maybe
quad core and you have a two gigahertz
per core that exactly gives you four
times uh the four times
two it gives you eight gigahertz so more
or less this is what it is but what in
this case is it gives you eight
gigahertz of performance more or less
and it shows as a two virtual cpus on
your task management and this is exactly
what um
what you'll get so make sure you
understand more or less how much
capacity you need and plan ahead because
it's going to be easier for you to plan
uh
and
you know
and and and deploy the systems that are
more or less what uh what needs to
handle another thing
is let me just increase the block size
is trained staff that's very important
make sure that the people that deploying
um
applications and the point the systems
in aws fully understand and they are
trained to accommodate the
the required performance and um and
components of every single system make
sure that people are aware of the latest
technologies as well as the latest
instance type and instance types because
aws constant comes up with the new ones
different sizes one thing but they also
have a different um architecture they
have instances that are based uh i will
oh i will get to all of this in the
future once when i start this lesson two
but just to give you an idea they have
an instance type c which actually stands
for the compute power which means they
give you more cpu but they take away a
memory they have a memory base so m um
uh sorry m is actually not memory based
m is actually universal will give you a
good balance between cpu and will give
you good balance between memory you have
um you have a storage um
high type instances which will give you
kind of okay balance on on on memory and
cpu but what they'll give you is a huge
amount of storage as well as the good
performance for the storage so if you
need to track through lots of logs or
have very i o intensive applications you
quite likely want to choose them because
you know that you are guaranteed the
good performance between those two
so
one of the last ones is support
contracts now there are a few
uh levels by default you're on the free
support contract it's it's okay it
doesn't really give you any perks or
benefits and i'm gonna give you a
breakdown of that as we go along in the
future um
personally i worked pretty much through
all different support contracts all the
way to enterprise which by the way costs
ten thousand dollars a month yep that's
the cost or
uh
whichever is greater which means if your
systems for example um cost a million
pounds a month then they take 10 of the
system and whichever is greater you have
to pay that one um
so so i will explain this exactly to you
in in the next few slides because we're
going to be getting that very very soon
um
i have a question from challenger
regarding what is t2 micro slash nano
instance
um
is this regarding the cpu and and
performance
challenges
i presume it is i'm still waiting for
chandra to reply but i can actually
show you this
basically t2
instant style it's a it's a very very
interesting instance and
um it's a little bit scary instance to
use and i'm gonna explain why you can
see here from um
from
from my cpu computer unit
that is a burstable ecu and what that
what does it mean well it doesn't
specify how many gigahertz of power i
have right well it doesn't but what it
does specify is number of virtual cpus
you have now what aws came up with is
ingenious
idea that they can give you a title type
instance
and
what they do
is when you don't use the instance you
basically gain credits for cpu which
means over time if you don't use it
you're actually getting more and more
credits
and then you can actually use those
credits when you have a very task
intensive uh operations that probably
happen maybe once or twice overnight and
then you basically bend through them
what happens when you bend through
completely well it gives you a kind of
low performance but it's a stable low
performance
if you have lots of credits because you
build them over let's say whole day and
you want to embed them through the night
you then basically run all those
operations you want and it will go
first into like extremely powerful box
all the way up to pretty much i think
one two or three or even four
gigahertz of power and it will process
that while burning the credits i will
get to the credits in the future i just
wanted to mention this right now
especially when you're discussing easy
two and there is a whole section about
that as well so no worries about it if
you don't really understand it at the
moment i will show you all this in the
future slides
so let me go back to our presentation
change management
basically all you need to remember is be
aware of how change affects the system
um and that are basically allowed to you
so you need to plan productivity which
means that you need to make sure that a
people don't have permissions that are
overblown that can destroy production
environments and you need to monitor
make sure you monitor all the systems um
you need to monitor all the systems
which means that you are aware that
production system is up and running and
also automates responses to kpis which
means that you can um
basically automate specific tasks um and
and all the all the um
all the actions can be fully automated
and can be for example emailed to you
that is very
important let me go further
and then we have air failure management
now
what i'm gonna do
is like this
so internal management a key to managing
failure is the frequent and automated
testing of the systems of area and a
thorough recovery and that enables
basically that enables the cloud um to
to to be recovered
basically
think of it like that
um
think of it like that temporary copies
of all your systems to verify uh the
sorry launch temporary copies of all
your systems to verify recovery
processes that is very important you
have ability to copy the whole systems
across and make sure that they are fully
working as well as your full access to
copies to copy all the files from let's
say s3 to make sure there are uh valid
and there are um
and there are
they're not corrupted so make sure once
in a while you run a copy to make sure
that all the data is intact to be honest
i worked with aos for quite a while and
i can tell you that
whenever i we ever uploaded aws as far
as it was not corrupted on r and before
we sent it was actually never corrupted
on aws which doesn't mean that's the
case for everyone i was maybe just lucky
but amount of system i work with and
amount of companies i've worked with
can
determine that it's not very likely that
it will happen
another one
is set up automation to uh
react to monitoring data in case of
failure it's very important we use this
system called cloud watch we can specify
a set of specific thresholds we can sp
specific rules saying hey you know what
if as if you on my server any server
within my um you know whole environment
goes beyond i don't know 75
for more than five minutes
maybe actually email me about that or
email the whole group or initiate
specific tasks and you can pretty much
specify what does you want maybe add
extra uh resources
another thing is store all your data for
future use in the aws three as we
discuss s3 is extremely bulletproof and
solution that stores all your data and
it's it's it's extremely good place it's
very unlikely that any file from s3 will
ever get corrupted or disappear
never happened to me and it i've never
seen anything like this happening and i
heard from anyone about that um
and again
you can set up a versioning or you can
also set up a place here later on to
make sure that all your data is double
protected
so going to the next slide
performance and efficiency
amazon defy defines performance
efficiency as the ability to use
computing resources efficiently to meet
system requirements to maintain that
efficiency as demand change as
technology evolved now because amazon is
extremely elastic environment and
elasticity is something you're gonna
hear a lot in fact um
if you think about it every other
service that you can think of aws
everything is elastic so um
ec2 for example stands for elastic cloud
compute which already has elasticity in
it so there are lots of other systems
that
will have e in front in fact lots of
services will have
elastic or or any other name and they
are very famous for it so let's go and
discuss more features about that aws
provides products such as nosql and
media transcoding machine learning as a
service which increases performance
efficiency allows you to
let me def let me take the drawing tool
democratize advanced technologies now
what you can do is you can utilize
amazon services to basically outsource
any other technology out there which is
amazing because it's extremely advanced
and it's fully managed go global in
minutes what it means you can actually
have a whole entire environment
being created in an automated fashion
from maybe your qa or maybe other system
and in a matter of minutes all you need
to do is basically deploy the same
template you deployed for qa and maybe
20 minutes later uh if the environment
is big you're going to have everything
up and running and guess what suddenly
someone comes to you and says hey you
know what i i need the same copy of the
system in another country can we do this
and you say sure we can you can take the
same
template that you deployed
switch the zone and basically deploy the
same
systems
in other countries straight away and
that's a global in minutes
what we also have is use serverless
architecture well aws doesn't only
consist of a physical servers that you
can use you can also use services like
lambda which we discussed a little bit
yesterday which allow you to perform uh
any code
operations on the serverless environment
yes well behind it's not really
serverless it still kind of operates on
some sort of hardware you just don't
know about it and you're not responsible
all you need to do is upload your code
to a lambda and say execute and you're
being charged only for what it does not
for actually having a server which in
many cases is awesome because if you
think about it you do not need to
maintain any of that anymore so all the
this useless time wasted on maintaining
all those physical boxes is actually
released to you and you can actually do
much cooler stuff
and also one of the other features is
that you can experiment often guess what
i can take a copy of my environment i
can actually copy it somewhere else call
it qa or i can call it an app or
whatever and i can experiment with it i
can actually change instant types on on
my copy i can maybe maybe to see if it's
a
you know performance is awesome i can
change the maybe database behind it to
make sure that um it can it can work
with a different type of database so
it's entirely up to you however you want
to do funny enough once you start using
serverless technologies you will have
much more time to experiment and that's
where the
advantage of this is
so
let's skip to the next question
next slide in this case
performance efficiency in the cloud
so one second
so as we all know aws provides products
such as nosql and and and the databases
that we actually uh discuss but they
also provide uh performance efficiency
in the services like compute like
storage database and time
space time
and trade-off
what it means
is
we can actually go right now to all of
them and i will discuss exactly in this
in the detail uh what every single of
them mean because i quite like to repeat
myself if i if we do it now
in the compute
uh
finding the the optimal server
configuration sometimes or amount of ram
and an amount of cpu that that you um
that you require can be a little bit
challenging and um aws gives you optimal
server configuration for the product in
the cloud that can
be based on the application design maybe
you have some sort of different usage
patterns or maybe configuration settings
um additional
id infrastructure can involve estimating
in advance that can lead to incorrect
server configurations and lower
performance efficiency so
basically
aws allows you to scale down enough so
increase the server
size and obviously compute allocated
with it and that's a
horizontal scale because you're making
boxes bigger or you can make more boxes
which is actually vertical and it's
entirely up to you it's entirely up to
the user if you want to make boxes
bigger that's fine if you want to make
more of them that is fine as well it is
entirely up to you
i have a question regarding
um
can we run sub uh code on lambda um i am
i cannot answer this question because i
simply don't know that depends on the
code if you will go to the aws website
and actually go into the lambda section
you can see what uh languages actually
lambda supports and you'll be able to to
to see if actually supports anything
from sub itself i never seen subroutine
number but maybe because the sub itself
is is its own environment but i'm sure
it will be integrated very soon if if if
it's not already in this sort of small
portion
uh i have another question where does
the code sit uh with uh
without an instance
uh if this is regarding the lambda
itself um i can tell you that when you
upload the code to lambda
the the code itself behind the scene
sits on the s3 you just don't know about
it and you don't see it in your s3
bucket
it's a special place in the s3 that aws
uh creates for you which is invisible to
user it's only visible through lambda
and you'll be able to see all of this in
there but behind the scene it sits on s3
so
um
so there you go
[Music]
a few more questions i see let me see
um
uh
what it means by allows you to execute
code without running an instance okay
that's actually very very very good uh
question
imagine situation and i want to explain
uh
i want to explain the concept of lambda
here a little bit if
if if i may
if you have ec2 instance
then this particular instance will have
a hard drive and then normally you would
put a code here yeah
and then you will execute
any operation to execute your code
on on from your hard drive so in theory
it sits on the on the hard drive itself
now when it comes to lambda it is not a
physical box lambda is a service
that takes the file that sits quite
lightly somewhere in alumni repository
behind the scene quite likely s3 but
we don't know that because lambda or aws
doesn't say any of that and whenever you
want to run your code you basically
initiate lambda and that will basically
take your function and run and outputs
data or does whatever you you program it
to do and you only pay for
the amount of time it's spent and the
amount of resources it computed
in order to execute your your code
so it physically doesn't sit on the on
on on the hardware flag here let me know
yes probably somewhere behind the scene
on s3 it does sit on on the drive but
it is invisible to us and i wouldn't
really worry what it says um we all know
it's secured and it's only available to
account that all i can tell you right
now
that means that you don't reserve an
instance uh that's correct i that that's
correct um the beauty of of lambda is
that you don't need to provision um
resource um for like like in ec2 so you
don't need a server anymore that you
occasionally run the code against all
you can do is actually upload your code
to a lambda and then whenever you need
to execute it you push a button and it
does all the processing automatically
behind the scene so yes some sort of
resource is allocated to you for the
specific time but that's all it is and
you only pay for a few seconds of the
code being executed
how long that will come to know where
the code sits a code is sitting on what
basis it finds it well
when you create lambda so-called
functions and i will be able to show you
this uh probably in session three as far
as i remember um
it when you create a function you need
to upload your code to the function and
that particular function you can execute
so lambda knows what the code says
because you just uploaded your code and
allocated to a function itself so london
knows to execute particular code because
you send it to do so
i hope i answer all your questions and i
would like to move a little bit more
forward
before we're gonna take a little bit of
break
so we're gonna go to storage the optimal
source the optimal storage solution for
a particular system various according to
your need whether you need it or no
now the beauty of aws is that
you in theory don't need to
overprovision stuff
uh you have
okay let me make it smaller again
you don't need to provision extremely
big hard drives and basically buy them
like two terabytes four terabytes or
even bigger uh and only maybe use one
percent of them all you can do is say
hey i actually need
storage that is maybe 10 gigs because my
application is 5 which i don't really
want to you know spend all this money
and you only pay for 10 gigs if suddenly
you need 20 1500 yes well you can't
resize the ebs volume or any block
service but what you can do is create a
new one that is 20 move your data
between and you pay only for 20 which is
extremely cheap so you don't pay upfront
you only pay for what you use
also file and file storage there are
there are um there are services that
will allow you to basically store uh
files like obviously uh s3 which is an
object storage and file that's kind of
related to each other and you only pay
for what you use which means you
uploaded one file and s3 charges you for
a one gig of storage a month which means
if one file for example is one mag that
means they will still charge you for one
gig because it's counted as a one gig
funny enough
but if you actually have a
you know uh 999
megs
they will charge you for one gig and you
only pay for amount of files you store
which is absolutely great and you don't
have to over provision stuff because
you're only spending money on on the
files you have a freedom you can say you
know what i i don't really want to keep
so many copies of my of my systems and
i'm paying for lots of money so i'll
just remove them and once you remove all
those copies from s3 suddenly the space
is released and and and you only pay for
what you use
also uh type of uh throughput you are
requiring every single instance uh
bigger gets
more speed between the instance itself
and the hard drive
there is if you have a t2 micro and i
can show you this here
i'm gonna remove this if you have t2
micro um itself that is highlighted
it shows in here
uh tbs optimize maximum bandwidth it's
not available because it's such a small
instance they cannot guarantee
performance of the of the network but
you go for anything like m4 large for
example and they can't guarantee that
the network speed between a hard drive
and the instance is at least or
pretty much similar to 450 megabits
that's a guarantee obviously bigger you
get
more speed you will get a get which
means you can allocate
your needs based on not only storage but
also how much data will be flying
between and how often you access your
data
so i hope
i hope that
that that explains a little bit
um let me delete this
also you can be charged how frequently
you access your data now when you put
the data on the s3 itself you pay for
the storage only but every single time
you do operation on it like read and
write or change or modify or delete you
pay for that now aws will charge you
something like a 0.01 u.s cent for like
a million operations which quite likely
in the smaller or medium systems you
probably even never notice on your bill
and i mean that
usually on the big systems we have bills
for like uh maybe three four million a
month and the cost for frequent access
data is maybe 50
which means it's absolutely nothing so
it is amazing how to it can get but bear
in mind that they can charge you for how
frequent you're using your data
and one of the last things is how
available and durable the data is you
can have a different storage types of s3
which we will discuss in detail uh very
very soon and depending of
how
redundant and available your data you
want it to be
they will charge a different amount of
money if you want your data to have
ninety nine point nine nine and then
eleven nines basically they will charge
you uh zero zero point uh zero point
zero three pounds but if suddenly you
say you know what actually 99.99
is fine with me because it's still okay
then selling the cost goes like twice
down which for most of the people it's
it's it's okay
you know you don't you don't run some
special systems that must persist of
data for forever so it's it's good
um
i can see the question here how is the
ebs different from s3 what sort of data
is stored in ebs
it's a very good question now it is
important to remember what ebs is and
what s3 is f3 is a service and which
allows you to store files as objects
it's not indexed and you don't you
cannot attach s3 to your to your
instance just just just like that
because it's not behaving as a hard
drive it more or less acts like a
dropbox when you upload file to the
dropbox you then get a link to this
drive to this file and then you can
click on the link and you can download
the file that's more that's what it is
what ebs is is more or less like iscsi
or maybe for those who don't know what
is it's basically like a network drive
attached to the network via the network
cable or fiber or any other means
which means that you can see
entire content of the hard drive because
it's presenting itself like that but
and also you can index all the files
which means when you're using windows
and you click on the double click on the
folder you see the content of it with s3
you cannot so that's the difference
between those two i i hope i explained
so
going further
now
databases the optima the optimal
the optimal database solution for
particular systems can vary based on
requirements and consistency how
available there are how partition
tolerance and latency and
amazon provides you multiple options
they have options like rds which is a
fully managed
relational database you can use
ms sql you can use
oracle here
you can use mysql basically pretty much
any engine you can think of quite likely
rds
is able to
um to provide um and the video of that
is scalable as well because ids comes
with the different types and sizes so
you can fully scale uh to what you need
so when you're starting a new database
and it's small that's great but when you
grow when you grow and you have more
traffic you can suddenly make the
database bigger and you're just gonna
pay a little bit more for it but there's
no point of over uh over uh blowing the
the size of the instance at the
beginning because you probably would
have been used but you have to pay for
it
also
another database that is very well known
recently is
dynamodb it's amazon's
version of the database available only
through aws it doesn't consist of any
equal out there
it provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale that is very
important now what it is it's a fully
scalable uh managed database that if you
program towards it you can have hundreds
of thousands of servers behind and the
database itself will scale up and down
without you even knowing to make sure
that it provides the same performance no
matter what the traffic is and that's
important you can also change the number
and type of all the nodes uh
in the redshift for example which we
discussed before it's basically a a data
a database called a collection
collector
that allows you to basically harvest
lots of data from different databases
and perform specific operations so for
example when you're just storing the
data in the redshift you can have a
minimum amount of nodes but then you
suddenly want to operate on that and
have specific
analysis of your data and you're going
to run multiple systems against it and
you need performance in this case you
can just give up the performance just
basically i want more it will grant you
the performance video pretty much
without within seconds and you can up
you can run all your operations which
means that
you only pay when you use it then once
you finish you can scale it down and you
only pay for storage that's that's the
beauty
also
it will allow you to
use databases like aurora or install
your own databases from templates like
amis now one of the cool features of aws
that you will notice quite likely is
that you can take images of
your vmware export them into the ovf uh
of your or ova or ovf format and you can
basically import it into aws so if
you're running currently vmware in your
environment you can pretty much take all
your servers and convert them into aws
format and run them there which is
absolutely great because you don't need
to recreate any of that again especially
when you have complex setup
we use this very often when we do a
system migrations um it's kind of easy
and straightforward we call it lift and
shift because it's basically lifting
whenever it's on premise and and by
shifting it to the the cloud it's not
probably the greatest way of doing that
and there are a few things um
that will um
that will probably change like ip
address for example is one of the things
because on-premise you have different
range than quite like you have in aws
and if the application is sensitive to
ip change then you might have a problem
with that you can
but you can change application to
accommodate that and obviously any move
from a physical or vm anywhere it's
usually a problem
now um
we are on the slide 30
and
there are about uh 120 30 slides in this
deck
and
i would need to accelerate a little bit
i will still give you lots of examples
as i kind of tend to do
uh but i will try to take a little bit
less and
we will try to speed up a little bit to
s to get as much as we can during
today's session and i hope that's that's
okay with all of you and i do apologize
if if um
if we're gonna speed up a little um so
we discussed the databases we're gonna
now go
to
a space time trade of as i mentioned
before aws allows you to
allocate more memory or more storage or
cpu in the different types of instances
which actually makes it
much more efficient because you don't
need to pay for everything you can only
focus on exactly what what you need
which is exactly uh great if you have a
cpu intensive tasks you can specify a
instance that has more cpu than memory
if you have a database type that catches
lots of things well memory would be
better so that's pretty much
what it allows you to do
now we're going to go straight into the
cost optimization
what the amazon says about that is that
it is ability to avoid or eliminate a
needed cost of some optimal resources
basically
amazon encourages encourages you to
optimize your environment and to the
most efficient cost because possible by
any means and we now gonna jump straight
and we're gonna see what kind of options
we have
we have um
we have transparency that edibles gives
you in fact aws actually refreshes their
account you use every night which means
you can actually see daily use and the
breakdowns which means any action you
take you can actually trace it back and
you can see how much the change costed
you uh over overall and also they they
break it down to every single service
that you use which means you can
actually even better visualize where the
money is going
you can use a minus services to reduce
the cost of ownership this is actually
very important now if you think about it
to manage a database you need first of
all you need a server some sort of that
sits somewhere quite likely someone is
managing that if it's in the data center
you have a bunch of people running
making sure that the
electricity is provided cooling is
working and you need to make sure that
someone actually built the server for
you as well as someone manages the os on
on the server itself and there are lots
of people involved in all of those
operations most of the time when you
have a small office everything falls
into you um but in the bigger
environments there are roles that people
are doing now what managed services uh
will do it will do everything for you
going to do is basically upload data to
the database for example and just manage
that everything else will be fully
managed by aws it is a little bit more
expensive
than running the same database in a on
the ec2 for example but again looking
from cost ownership so all those little
things that we mentioned quite actually
long term it's cheaper to run minor
service than do it yourself
also uh trade capital expense for
operating uh expense that's related
exactly to this you might be given only
amount a fixed amount of money to run
your system which means that you it's it
can be up to you if you if you're gonna
make it big or small but you must fit
within a specific um
bracket just because it was approved and
you have all the tools to do that um you
can scale down the system up and down
because maybe you have a sale uh maybe
you have some sort of more um
performance needed uh tasks on on your
backend systems and in this case you can
scale up and down just to meet the
demand of the previous section which
means that capital expands also
you can stop spending money on the data
center operations guess what aws is a
data center and is fully managed you're
paying aws per hour as we mentioned
before so you don't need to focus on any
of that which means you have all the
time in the world to actually focus on
the system itself you want to design
your application rather than waste time
on managing this
without pretty much the end
so what i'm gonna do is jump to the next
slide straight away
um
also aws gives you ability to match
supply and demand as we mentioned before
you for example can uh increase the
amount of uh
servers you have because maybe you have
a sale or maybe you have some sort of
event that requires more processing
power but then during the night you
basically have not much traffic because
everyone is asleep which means the
number of servers can go down and up
depending on on on the needs and that's
exactly what it is cost effective
resources now adams itself gives you
ability to spin up at very small boxes
as we kind of saw on the website the
list is very long and quite likely you
get a custom with about maybe five or
six of them i have pretty much my
favorites they use for everything um
and and and you will notice that kind of
they're kind of a little bit universal
you can use them for multiple different
things but it allows you to go up and
down whenever you need also aws is
allowing you to have expenditure
awareness which means they will show you
on the daily basis how much you're
spending and that's important you can
also
set up a a limits and alert saying that
you know what i i don't want that
account to spend more than let's say a
thousand pounds a month because that's
my fixed budget for my it and in this
case you can set up a threshold around
maybe 800 dollars and whenever you reach
it you get emails saying hey you
actually spend 800
and actually it can be on you if you
want to reduce amount of service within
the pool or you can go to your boss and
say hey i actually need more money
because we were using this uh very very
um
you know we're using this a lot uh let
me just let's scroll this a little bit
and um
one of the last ones is optimizing over
time as i mentioned before quite like in
the beginning you will be given a task
of deploying some sort of system which
is great you don't know how big the
system requires to be they will tell you
more or less maybe i need that amount of
cpu and maybe i need that that that and
and
that's fine nobody really knows it's a
guest game at this stage but as time
goes and your production and the
environment you actually mentioned uh
that you just built it it goes into
production and has lots of traffic
you'll be able to understand over time
how much resources are really
used for that which means you'll be able
to optimize it make it smaller make it
bigger if required and make sure that
you're getting every single value out of
every dollar you give to aws so that's a
very good point here
i'll go straight into the next slide
now there are a few um uh ways you can
achieve much supply and demand you can
do this by auto scaling as we mentioned
this before and i will give you
uh much more details once we actually
reach this pretty much this in the
future uh slides you can have a
time-based approach as i said for
example during night you can set up that
a number of servers can go down to maybe
two for redundancy but during the day
you you you want five because you know
that your systems are kind of used so
that's a very good example you have you
can have event driven approaches which
we mentioned so if the load goes beyond
specific threshold then something will
happen and also you can have a cube
based approaches which means you can
utilize
services like s sqs which is a basically
a cubing service for all the requests
and
and more stuff more things that are in
the queue more servers will spin up and
be able to process that which means you
can have multiple approaches whichever
suits you and your your needs for
application and business will will will
do and aws gives you pretty much all
those options just to make just make
sure you understand them to be able to
use them
now because efficiency resources
you can have on demand instances
it is instant that you launch and pretty
much it you pay full price for it um
which is just a little bit of wasteful i
would say because you you don't get any
discounts and if you're running those
instances pretty much for all entire
time for like a year let's say then
quite likely you overspend on it a
little bit the reason is
in this case we would go for real sorry
sorry for my big blog in this case you
would go for reserve instance which
actually reserved for a year or or three
and the cost for the instance goes
anywhere from uh 20 maybe 30 all the way
to 60 70 percent of the whole year the
the downside of that is in this case you
probably won't pay per hour anymore you
can actually pay upfront but you can
make sure that the cost for the instance
will actually be guaranteed for the
whole year which means you can save up
to 70 percent of the costs if you know
that the server will be running for a
year like production grade environments
you can have a spot instances what it is
and how it works is basically you
uh
be the
amount of money that you want to pay for
specific instances so for example
if you have an instance that costs uh
0.50 usc per hour and that's the on
demand price um let me just draw a
dollar sorry for the good thing and you
can say that i want this particular
instance to be launched as a spot
instance but i don't want to pay more
for it than maybe 0.20
uh
20 cents
you can do that it's a spot instance now
if aws has enough resource to
accommodate such requests uh then the
cost per per hour for such an instance
can go down um to maybe something like
even five pens or something else you
specify that you maximum want to pay 20
cents and which is great so for the
entire time that the instance
is actually running and the the bid for
instance is this is not released which
means your bid is actually higher than
the price of the real instance spot
instance behind it will be fine but
there is a trick to it what happens if
the demand for specific instance goes up
and that happens very often you have a
christmas sale you have a black friday
and suddenly all the resources those
unused resources that aws had suddenly
spiked up because everyone wants to use
aws like crazy so what happened what
happens is suddenly because of this
parquet instance goes actually up and
most of the cases even goes beyond the
price on demand sometimes we've seen
behavior like the instance goes all the
way to like 10 dollars an hour so it's
20 times more expensive so you need to
be careful when you're bidding for it
and i will give you more examples about
this before uh
later in in the in the session um i can
tell you that more or less on the daily
basis if you have non-critical systems
and you just want to run something just
to test you can save up to eight times
the cost of the on demand instance which
is absolutely great so you can test
stuff without breaking the bank
you can also use services like aws rds
which is actually um
basically minus database so you're
saving all the cost of licensing of all
the hardware and everything else and you
only take care of of data itself and
also dynamic b which is the same as rds
with exception is its own engine and you
only pay for the resource and amount of
storage you have which is even cheaper
than that
so i want to skip to the next slide as
quickly as we can so we can cover as
much as we can
expenditure
awareness what you need to do and make
sure you understand is that uh you can
allocate a tags to end instances or
environments what the tag is is
basically a little bit of text that you
can allocate to ec2 pretty much s3
anything you want so you can basically
target your resources so imagine in your
company you have two departments one is
it and one is maybe sales and both of
those departments they they run on the
same account however they pay for their
own bill and how would you determine
which which account spends how much if
you only get one bill what you can do is
allocate the attack and i'm gonna show
you all those tags later on as well um
and based on that you basically get a
breakdown based on the tags which means
uh sales guys will get there and you
will still get one bill but you will get
also a breakdown of actually the time
that that you specified was that much
and the tag that was that much so you
can actually invoice but your
subsections of your company or even your
clients if if you require
the cost allocation report you can
actually have a full breakdown of what
you're spending money on and where
you're spending money so if you receive
the bill and you for example using
multiple services like ec2 and rds and
using c3 and pretty much everything else
else out there it will give you a very
detailed breakdown and i mean it's very
detailed up to how many hours you're
running particular instance and how much
it costed you that is how much it it
detailed it is
you can also set up billing alerts as i
said before if you for example one don't
want to spend more than a thousand
pounds set up building a little bit less
and you're gonna get alert every single
time you're reaching that
spot so you don't get a surprise when
you open envelope with a build from aws
also you can use aws simple monthly
calculator which i will show you as well
which allows you to predict the cost of
the environment because you can actually
build you can drop a drag and drop
almost the boxes and the server sizes
and based on that it would determine how
much it will cost to run such a thing
per month so when you're doing a little
uh designs for little uh projects or
big projects you can actually predict
the monthly running cost of the
environment and and you can maybe adjust
it because nobody really knew that it
would cost so much so you can maybe
scale down a little bit on the database
or maybe
have less servers and just to need the
the required cost
so skipping to the next
basically also aws allows releases of
new products and services therefore it's
good idea to
reassess the existing setup to the most
efficient way every single month i
always get a new
notification from aws hey we have this
new service i'm not gonna go exactly on
all of them right now here because
that's just for the sake of the
presentation but every single month
there's something new hey we introduced
this hey we have that and suddenly you
notice that quite likely the service
that you introduce it can be used in
your company and maybe if it cannot you
can ask yourself a question how can i
use it to maybe uh make it my life
easier and maybe make the company
save money in the future if they want to
use such a thing so it's very important
to understand that with time new
services are being introduced
and
you can stop using
old fashioned resources and go fully
managed which means the cost of
ownership is much much lower
um i'm assessing more information
of course aws architecture center
provides guidance and application
architectural best practices uh to build
uh highly scalable
applications in the cloud
you will be able to read pretty much
every single article on a aws website
once you actually sign into your account
um and you'll be able to have the best
approaches ever created by the by the
aws guys and lots of other market
leaders and and they will show you what
kind of examples you have is exactly
great and in this case you'll be able to
to imagine and test all of those
different
principles
as i said before you have a different
web application scenarios that you can
actually say hey i actually need a fully
scalable web application hosting uh
system and it will actually show you
different reference architectures you
can use you can have uh batch processing
you can have a fault tolerance you can
have pretty much anything else you can
think of is probably there so it's maybe
worth before you start playing around
with it see how other people did it so
you can understand how it can be done in
the most modern and efficient way
um
um i have a question here here from
artists should i shall we make an aws
account uh now for the for the class i
would say i would say
uh it would be advisable for you to to
to open an account it's it's free it
will ask you for credit card details at
first but it will not charge you a penny
for it and you can utilize lots of uh
three tier um
you can utilize lots of three-tier
resources from aws like ec2 and rds as
long as they're small they're kind of
free for actually yes you can play
around and understand how it works and
you will actually quickly realize that
as complex as it looks at first it's
actually extremely simple play around
with it make sure that um that you
control the cost as well so every single
time it will say hey it won't cost you
that much well
don't go overboard go small instances on
purpose otherwise you will pay for stuff
that you don't really use and you can
try and play around with it so i advise
to do that maybe not at the moment
currently but maybe if you want to try
and see how everything works go for it
now aws technical white papers aws
provides a white paper is pretty much
for everything you can think of um and
it's actually worth reading that it's
it's it's it's kind of technical but
they do not go overboard which is very
good and and i i read pretty much
majority of the white papers because
lots of um systems that i actually
design they were designed before and
someone already came up with the idea
and having a knowledge in your head of
somebody else's work will give you a
huge advantage because if your boss
comes to you and says hey so can you
actually give me can you design the
system i'm like actually sure i can do
it today and he'll be like oh actually
he said knows it all what sam doesn't
sebastian knows how other people did it
and that's the truth so we're all here
to share knowledge and we are here um to
to to to to have the access to knowledge
and white papers is very good place to
do that
um i have a question from joranjit is
there any plan to host unix uh isu
or solaris um instances on edibles in
the future i actually asked this
question uh quite recently as well
at the moment there is no and not not
not a
requirement for them it's not on the
roadmap because the need for that is
absolutely minimal they do want to
implement this sometime in the future
very very far but it's not on the paper
so i will say no at this current stage
you can also use a quick reference
deployment in aws basically you can
choose what you want and it will spin
out the whole environment for you
but the white papers you have it it will
actually show you how it's being done so
you can have a link server you can have
exchange server you can have a remote
desktop and basically it will say how
people did it you can know that by the
html or pdf so go for it uh have a look
if you're interested and you'll be able
to understand how other people did it on
on the cloud
there are some case studies as well
that's being done by the big companies
like netflix airbnb nokia yield and many
others and it's actually very good which
means that all those companies have um
a trust and they went as far as using
aws for their business now netflix
itself uh was a huge huge user of of aws
for a very long time uh airbnb is a
pretty much entirely sitting on on on
the on the on the cloud um i don't know
if you know but service called dropbox
that pretty much is very well known
in the whole entire world is actually s3
amazon s3 a bucket every single resource
that you ever upload and download from
there it all ends on the s3 and this
that's the core of the system as simple
as three and a little bit of rubber
around it uh with application that can
determine what file change on your
computer or on the s3 itself and you
have a whole business worth
multi-billion dollars right now only
using a single service from aws called
s3 which is absolutely
amazing
now we're going to jump straight into
planning and design um let me go to the
first
uh
slide planning and designing in this
section we'll learn about scaling loose
coupling redundancy cost optimization
automation security
itself so let's jump straight into it so
we're gonna follow this particular path
scalability and that's very important so
let's jump to this what scalability
gives you is basically virtually
unlimited on demand capacity so when you
can scale so you can scale whenever you
need it
or not um where there are two ways of
scale vertically and horizontally as we
mentioned before
a vertical
is basically making box bigger and
horizontal is making more boxes of the
same size so that's possibility
pretty much as i said before i'm just
gonna skip this and basically a vertical
is uh
uh is basically more memory and more
resources
horizontal is actually adding additional
server to be able to handle uh more
people
now we're going to get to state
state less applications i know we had
the question before we got in stateless
and and um and stateful now i'm going to
define this as follows a stateless
application is one that needs no
knowledge of the previous interactions
and stores no session information an
example of that for example would be a
web server that provides the same web
page to any end user which is stateless
which means
nothing really on the website changes
maybe even if it's dynamic it doesn't
really matter there is no information
kept about the user which means you can
add any number of servers it's still
stateless now
pretty much that's what it is
um
i'm gonna define stateful a little bit
later it's somewhere in the slides as
well
push model what it is it's a popular way
to distribute workloads across multiple
resources uh by using a load balancer
such as the aws load balancer what it
actually is is whenever the requests are
coming to the eob um
through here the elb will push all those
requests to all of your resources and
that's a push model
there is also a full model that we will
actually see now and what it is is it's
like a message queue so for example you
have a queue of requests that you need
to um fulfill and the queue filled up
and basically the queue filled up and
then you have more resources so you're
spinning up more boxes to be able to
process this particular um
request and they pulling from from the
queue which was uh which exactly uh
stores all the tasks
um so that's it here
and then we have stateless uh components
we have a
we can define them and define them as we
have
dynamodb which is a stateless we have a
mysql server we have amazon s3 and we
have efs
components components in the
architecture can be made stateless by
not storing anything on the local file
system and instances storing user or
session based information in the
database like what i just mentioned
which means
all those actually are stateless
and then stateful information obviously
one of the uh big advantages of the
stateful is that it persists the data so
some layers of the architecture cannot
be turned into stateless components for
example databases uh which by definition
obviously
consists of data and good example is rds
and then rdp those databases storing the
data and then they
they actually have constant state
available of this particular data
now we can also have
distributed processing in the situations
when large amounts of data
has to be processed we instead of having
all of this
running on a single box uh like in this
example here uh which obviously it's a
little bit of overkill we can distribute
this uh every single of those little
components to a dedicated server to to
to perform its own operation this way we
can make sure that the little box will
not explode halfway through and
basically stop working and also we can
make sure that we have some sort of
redundancy which means if maybe one
server fails which is fine we still have
three tasks that are still performed as
as they should hence it gives us a
distributed processing
now what is worth mentioning as well is
that aws need to kind of think about
this from a little bit different
perspective when you work in a normal
iit infrastructure environment you treat
servers as as as commodity you treat
them as something that you always will
have obviously upon conversation will
explode or will be at the commission
because they are way too old but you
treat them as a commodity or something
that you um you you own with aws it's uh
itself you don't you treat service as
fully disposable uh resource which means
if you have a simple task of maybe
running overnight and and maybe indexing
some data or maybe copying some files
from place a to b just because you have
to you can spin up a whole box as we
have here and the whole box can actually
have programmatically configured a
specific operation like take file from a
and do something with it and put
somewhere in a place b and actually once
you finish you know what just kill
yourself but basically just decommission
yourself hence you don't pay for it and
that's exactly disposable resources you
only spin it up when you need it yes you
might use it for production environment
that those servers might be running 24 7
and hence it's not really disposable in
this case but any other task it can so
that's the benefit of aws in this case
automate compute resource initiation so
when you spin up a new server you can
have
you can have a few things you can have
it via bootstrapping so it's a process
that during the booting of the server
you can perform specific actions like
for example when you're spinning up a
brand new box you say to it hey actually
you know what install uh let's say
any service you want something like
maybe a
um
ftp client and once you connect it once
you install that connect uh somewhere
through it and download some file by an
ftp just because i have to and then
that's it and that's basically a
bootstrapping so it's a whole process
from a moment you spun up the box all
the the all the way until the box is
ready and then you can perform specific
operations you can achieve the same by
actually having golden image which is a
copy of a server that is already with
the application after bootstrap and then
you take a copy of it uh in a state in
in the point of time and then you can
deploy multiple of those images or you
can have a hybrid in fact we use hybrid
a lot what we do in in a
in a real world what we do is we create
a golden image of a server with all the
os and everything sitting on it like
even security and all the policies and
everything on it and it's an empty box
it doesn't have anything except a bare
base so what we do is we have a hybrid
approach then what we do is basically
deploy a specific application based on
what the server needs to do we take this
particular copy and the voice staff if
you have a different kind of box that's
fine it's still using the same resource
but it will push different application
so it will look a little bit different
but the base of the server is exactly
the same so hybrid is very common and
very well used
so as i mentioned bootstrapping is
basically taking a data processing
through ec2 and making sure that it
comes out with the full application
colon images as i mentioned before uh
can be
either uh done via the
sorry for that can be either done by a
snapping uh snapshotting the ec2 and
then creating this
new instance out of it you can do the
same with the rds create a snapshot and
then create a brand new database which
has exactly the same copy of the data
you can do the same with the ebs which
is actually a storage volume for ec2 and
then you can snapshot it and you can use
this to copy the data between let's say
at two regions or attach it to another
server and
the the most common scenario is
basically you take an ec2 you create a
ami of it and then you deploy multiple
systems so if you have let's say web
server that you have a static data on it
then
you can create ami out of it
and then whenever you need we deploy
more based on your needs
and it's always the same it takes few
seconds under a minute we need to speed
it up and you have exactly the same copy
of the server in every single place not
only locally but you can also have it
across the world and that's the beauty
and benefit of it
so as i mentioned before you can also
have a hybrid approach which i'm going
to skip for now because i kind of
already explained it
and also make sure that you understand a
simple concept that you can have a whole
infrastructure as a code that is very
important this is what aws is about what
you can do is you can specify hey i have
a my system consists of two web servers
and one database server at the end yes
you can create this by hand and you can
try to create a copy of it or every
single time but why if you know that
you're going to use this all the time
why not just taking this and actually
converting this into the
amazon cloud fund
no sorry sorry
you can use a cloud formation for that
and you can basically deploy the same
code at the same
system in multiple places now what
cloudfront is is you can apply these
techniques discussed earlier to entire
environments in the individual resources
and automate automation services as we
mentioned before uh there are multiple
aws um automation services that are
available to you as a developer for
example you can use elastic bean stock
which obviously is an awesome place
because all you need to do is deploy a
code to it that you want and then
basically deploy the whole environment
and build everything for you you can
have easy to auto recovery
um
um can i go slow yes because sorry uh
the reason i spotted a spun up and uh
speed up a little bit was that uh we
really really have um
about one hour and ten minutes to finish
about 40 slides and i wanted to make
sure that we do that as much as we can
um
because i don't really want to leave
this session uh unfinished if possible
and i do apologize for that
um i will try to slow down a little bit
we have auto scaling which allows you to
scale more resources on demand based on
the
um
based on the on the resources needed you
have a cloud watch alarms and events
which will allow you to actually specify
uh specific events that happens based on
the on the metrics that you you have
um
yes i will try to speak a little bit
slower um i'm sorry for that um also you
can have a work uh
ops work and life cycle event which
actually means that you can redeploy a
newest version of the code and every
single time you have a new release and
that code will be deployed to all your
systems automatically and update every
single server
and obviously you have a
loose coupling what it means is that you
don't necessarily want to er to um
to rely on a single point of failure so
when you have a system that uh you have
a storage and you have a web service in
case of one server fails it doesn't
really matter because uh the the storage
that you use which in this case can be
s3 can still connect uh to a web server
and application can happen and a
specific action can take place no matter
if you have a web server one down two
down doesn't matter
you still have resource to do that so
you removing a single point of failure
in this in in this case
also what you have is a well-defined
interfaces every single resource that we
said before is basically uh going
through
amazon api gateway and every single
resource you always
provision either it's a storage either
it's a computer or database everything
is
programmatically defined as an api you
can use a console for that which which
most of you probably will and if you if
you if you want to
do it more automated you can actually
use api calls to the aws and you can
deploy exactly the same resources via
the api itself
now also um as we mentioned this before
um the elb itself
elb itself is aware of lots of servers
in the pool so you don't need to specify
ips itself and
hence service discovery it is aware of
the presence of all those servers and it
knows when they go down so that's
they lose coupling bit ensures the
services interact with each other and
without any previous prior knowledge of
their existence and that's all as a one
system which is actually integrated with
a elastic load balancing
also you can have asynchronous
integration what it is it involves the
use of
intermediate storage layers such as sqs
technique
in order to basically
make sure that the servers
that the servers can actually
pull they do not get overwhelmed with
the requests you push all the requests
to sqs which basically is a cube
sitting on this particular layer and the
queue can scale and grow as far as it
can but then more resources we spin
quicker the queue can
can can be tackled and the queue itself
can actually store virtually almost
unlimited amount of um
requests which means that
none of the requests will be ever lost
it will be just processed with a little
bit of delay if you have such a system
then you have a thing so also called
graceful
failure what it means is um
can i give a real world example of usage
of sqs sure sure i can
basically imagine situation that um
you have
a
a server that sends emails and
um
your system is
designed to basically generate email
every single time user interacts with it
and your server that sends emails has
very limited capabilities because
you don't really want it to cost a lot
so what you would do is every single
time instead of sending email directly
from your application to the email
server which can get overwhelmed when
there's a you know lots of requests
because there is a spike instead what
you can do is you can actually forward
all those emails to sqs service which
will uh take those emails and create
this as a task and then instead of this
you can take your mail certified to
connect directly to the sqs and pull
them automatically one by one which
means it can only do as fast and it as
it can so no matter how big the queue or
small queue is it will keep sending
emails as quickly as you can up until
the queue is empty obviously in the
situation like you have a spike where
the queue grows terribly quick the
server can only process stuff as quickly
as it can which is fine but in this case
you will not have a failure because the
key can go as far as it wants and it's
not critical because the email doesn't
need to be sent within the same second
it can be delayed maybe by a few minutes
and that's a real
example you have also service called uh
you have also a feature called
graceful failure what it means
is
with a system like route 53 which is a
basically uh
amazon's version of a dns you are
capable of deploying uh two
website locations um and
via one address something like a www dot
whatever whatever whatever you want uh
users can go to the primary source now
when the primary source is dead or
finding reason is unavailable you can
actually specify in the arrow 53
potential failure and it can
automatically redirect everyone using
exactly the same
link as before to the new location and
it's fully automated once the primary
comes back on it can then transfer
everyone back into the primary website
and that's all done by a single service
that is basically dns which is actually
very impressive
uh services not servers exactly aws is a
very well known um for implementing
pretty much as i said before lots of
services that are fully managed of
pretty much everything you can think of
so database is the rds which is exactly
fully managed database for you all you
need to do is connect it by a single
port and start sending requests machine
learning well there's not really a
service out there um
that you can create out of the box like
that
but aws went beyond and above and
created that for you so you can start
using this in your application analytics
yes you can build this yourself and you
can use maybe third party tools but aws
does have this feature so you can use it
uh you can use search and email all
those features are available to you as a
services but not servers so you only pay
for what you use and uh resources you
you require like amount of email maybe
you send or amount of search queries or
amount of analytics you want to generate
and so forth and so on and so on
databases
database usage is not restricted by
constraints of licensing support and
hardware availabilities and aws offer
fully managed easily scalable services
us and it's been worth mentioning aws
provides services like dynamodb elastic
cache rds redshift mysql db and oracle
and all of them are fully managed yes
you can have all of them as well with
maybe exceptional redshift as a as a
server that you wanna build yourself but
then you're gonna go into the point that
you have to manage that and why do that
if you can have aws doing this for you
for a fraction of the cost
now redundancy uh redundancy is a very
very important subject that nws always
wants you to know is
by redundancy we always mean that you
have more than one uh resource available
in case one server goes down you have
always redundancy so there are the tasks
can be always performed yes it might be
a little bit delayed because one server
can only do half of the operations that
two servers can but it still will be
performed which means you don't have a
downtime and redundancy on aws is taken
to another level they give you multiple
data centers they give you multiple
things they give you multiple of
everything you just need to know how to
use it and you need to enable this
because by default when you spin up one
server it's only in one data center so
that's important to remember
we also can use uh such a service as uh
as a standby redundancy what it means if
you have a database and in case
there is a production environment that
in in it goes down and the business
flows based on that is counted in in
hundreds of thousands of of dollars or
any other currency you really want to
think of they usually go for something
like a standby database and it's a very
common example in the uh in the aws you
can create a copy of that particular
database uh directly somewhere else
maybe in other region um and in case
there is a big failure you can quickly
fail over to the standby database and
we're gonna learn how to do this in the
future
sessions
and there is uh active redundancy what
it is is basically it's a lot load load
balancer it's fully integrated in the
service itself and provides you elastic
and fully redundant automatic active uh
connections to every single box which
means if one box fails it doesn't really
matter because the requests are
forwarded equally to all the remaining
boxes which means all your tasks are
still performed
also elastic load balancer gives you
ability to perform um
health checks as i mentioned before so
if for example your web server uh
doesn't respond on uh so it gives you
response to 100 that means something's
probably wrong with it
it will be removed from the poll and it
will be will only force traffic to two
healthy hosts which obviously um
will process the data on both of them
and it can be set up also in the way
that if this is if this particular
server is dead
it can launch a new one just to
accommodate always three servers in the
pool just in like this example
now
we have
now we have a durability of the data
we have we have a synchronous data we
have a synchronous data and a quantum
based and i think we're going to have
this explained in the next slide
yes synchronous replication is where
the changes
where the right operations and the and
the
to the primary source
are replicated in the real life to the
replication uh source which means that
all the servers are actually kept in a
sync almost near time because that
depends how far they are apart if you if
you have two servers that are based in
two different places in the world like
one is based in china another one is in
the u.s just just for sake of exercise
um
the latency between those is counted in
maybe like 400 500 milliseconds which
means the data that is synced it's not
gonna be real time it's gonna be always
little bit behind so that's what we call
synchronous replication
now a synchronous replication
what it is is basically a replication
that happens on the primary host and um
to the user the data is being written
but
the replication in the back end happens
behind the scene which means it can
happen
anytime after which means it's not real
time
and then we have a third type are called
quorum replication current-based
replication is a mix of both it's a
synchronous and asynchronous replication
it's basically a hybrid between those
two and
that's that basically i can i can tell
you that um it's a mixture of both
because
it can actually copy the data directly
in the near real and near time
replication but it doesn't have to and
that's exactly what it is
uh the question i have uh those
reputation today uh
is um is this a replication does
these replications doesn't depend on the
databases it doesn't need to depend on
the on the databases yes databases are
one of the
things that we can replicate and in the
future you will see that ids for example
allows you to take a single box and you
can create a with replicas or you can
have a standby servers and that's only
with one tick and that it's going to be
a synchronous you can have a synchronous
verification which means for example it
doesn't need to be database imagine you
have a file server and this particular
file server you must sync in the other
location in the world it doesn't need to
be real-time so what you can have is
that you can have a maybe simple
script or maybe some sort of command or
some sort of application that what it
will do
it will run every now and then probably
even overnight because it's uh the the
best time to do those things and it will
copy the data from source to the to the
destination
and sync them together however it's not
gonna be real time that's why it is uh
that
um
i have another question here is the
replication scheduling based or it can
run a while the application is being
used and accessible by a user it's
actually a very good question that will
all depend on your application some
applications for example like uh like a
um
like a website imagine you have um let
me just remove that imagine you have two
web servers
and
and between those two servers um you
want to make sure that the content of
those two web servers is exactly the
same and the reason is if it's not the
same and it's a one production
environment well then you have a problem
and so what you would probably even do
here you can introduce elastic file
storage
and that will make sure that the data is
basically written to one place and is
being actually replicated another and
that's one of our examples the example
that you don't want to use the uh
synchronous uh replication is um
another question from autis is is this
controlled by application or aws well
aws itself doesn't really give you as
long as it's a non-managed service it
doesn't give you any replication by
default if you use if you use services
like rds for example which is a fully
monitored service and you take the box
that you want to have a reputation
enabled it is a fully uh synchronous
replication uh delivered by aws which
means all the servers database servers
in the pool are actually being synced
in a real real time which means in one
fails the other one kick in and we'll
take over from the previous one from
exactly the same state so you the answer
to this is yes and no depending on what
service you use
so let me skip forward a little bit
and you have also a data center
resilience which means if for example
you can deploy your application in a in
the single uh
region let's say in in dublin well guess
what you can also have exactly the same
setup in the secondary one somewhere in
the u.s for example with exactly the
same uh
state and uh but everything off just
just just to make make sure that you
don't pay for it and you can have a full
dr uh
so disaster recovery uh scenario and if
there's a failure with the one data
center which is very unlikely because in
the past seven years aws never actually
went down and they had maybe a little
bit of service degradation based on the
amount of traffic they had they had a
few ddoses as well which they mitigated
very well um
if ever data center goes down
you can always forward to another data
center and enable all those resources by
just powering up around the boxes which
means you when they're off you don't pay
but when you turn them on you have a
full dr situation
let's skip another one quickly
so also
worth mentioning as i said before every
single region um
consists of multiple ac so availability
zones what it means
those are physical data centers and they
are located nearby in about i would say
anywhere between 20 and 50 miles apart
from each other because um that's a
physical
hardware and location
redundancy and they're all connected via
fibers between each other which means
every single time you spin up a server
you can choose which ac you want if you
want an a b or c and they will
physically be sitting in different data
centers which means if one fails for any
reason
well guess what you still have two data
centers available which doesn't really
make any difference to you and
applications still can continue to work
as normally
so next slide
shuffle charting fault isolation shuffle
shotting is a practice that sends a few
of the requests to some of the resources
this ensures that uh one uh uh let me
just
a shard of a resource is in a in
infected or down and the other charts of
resources will be up and running
basically what it means is you can set
up um you can set up systems in the way
that you can forward specific requests
to specific servers and make sure you
get correct responses if you don't you
can basically i
assume that the system or server behind
it it might not work correctly enhance
shuffle and charting and that's pretty
much what it is about
also as always optimize for cost
so
make sure
um basically right sizing that allows
you to choose appropriate size of
instances like ec2 rds redshift and
elasticsearch bear in mind it's up to
you what size you choose if you choose
too big and you pay huge amounts of
money well that's only your fault it's
not aws they give you ability to spin up
anything you want
and you have to pay for it it's pretty
much the same as you go to this to the
id store and you're trying to buy a
server for the database or a normal
server they ask you how much ram and how
much cpu and everything else you want
and if you're gonna say i want uh one
terabyte of ram and i wanna 16
processors and each one you know with
hyper trading and all this stuff they'll
give you a quote for half a million
pounds if not more and if you say yes to
it and use it only to to to basically
copy file from place a to b well it's
your own fault
in aws you make sure that you choose
appropriate size for the task you're
doing
now elasticity it's a very very good
subject i aws offers many elasticity
options to help you save money
so
i have a question here
uh on which database do we shuffle
shard
typically or do we do this on s3 we
normally don't shuffle um shuffle charts
on the databases uh basically if you're
using ids itself um
basically how aws works is that it
provides you the primary node and you
always connect to it by the uh via the
dns name that they provide so you know
you're not connecting ever to any
resource to aws via the ip address you
always use a dns name
um in this case they only provide you
with one and one server visible which
means you can write and read through it
what happens behind the scene it's the
replication if you enable that obviously
to the secondary machine and in case the
primary fails then what happens is dns
gets redirected to the other one so from
application nothing actually changes
which means still server is available
and i can still have the same host
hostname and i have response great let's
let's let's continue
communication
so coming back to the task here uh aws
provides you with horizontal scaling
which means you can add multiple boxes
also they give you vertical skating
which means you can make boxes bigger
and also you can shut down
non-production environments based on the
time and that's actually very good and
important you need to remember the
production systems pretty much are
running 24 7 if obviously uh you have
such an in in your case but there are
lots of other environments like
non-production dev testing qa staging
you name it i pretty much had it and
seen it all and funny enough the
mentality of people most of the time is
that they spin up those boxes and run in
those systems 24 7 just because when
developer wants to connect they will but
guess what developers only work from
let's say nine to five and that's it so
from five till nine so for quite a while
the server is not being used it sits
there it's basically doing absolutely
nothing and you keep paying for it why
in this case you can specify that i want
to shut down all my servers that are not
production between this time and this
time and turn them on in the morning
again which means you only pay for eight
hours of using the server in case of
1905 um and you don't pay for remaining
time then the services and does
absolutely nothing which actually um
it's actually about 70 cheaper just to
do it and you still have exactly the
same as the resources which is a very
very good trick with aws and you can
save loads of money
so i'm going to the next slide
now you also have different purchase
options
which one of them is on demand that
means that whenever you need instance
you just spin it up and most of the
instances that you spin straight away
would be probably on demand that means
you only pay a per hour whenever you
need it i would not recommend that for
long term commitments because it's not
efficient and that's important to
remember
reserved instances what reserved
instance is is your commitment that you
will have this instance or server time
or any other resource that aws provides
like even rds for at least a year in
this case if you're coming with aws for
a year you will have to use the same
instance size uh pretty much in the same
region and then what happens is
aws will charge you up front
money for this box and for the remaining
year for the whole year ahead you don't
have to pay for it so what's the perk
well the perk is simple you can save
anywhere from 30 as i said before to all
the way up to up until almost 70 percent
of the cost of the server which if you
think it's a huge amount of money
especially when you have lots and loads
of servers in in your organization and
you can actually
mostly apply reserve instances to
servers running in production
i have a question here reserved
instances means single tendency um
reserved instances means that you
reserve capacity um
um on a single box yes and you can have
multiple of those you can say i want 50
reserved instances of this size and
basically you pay 50 times whatever the
price is and then you just reserve this
for a year you can do it on the year
basis or you can do it up to three years
basis and if you're gonna go for three
years which most of you don't because
you don't really know if your systems
will be up running in three years then
you have even better discounts most of
the people go for one year because you
still get very good discount and one
year is not that much to commit towards
so
another one
spot instances as i already mentioned
before you bid on the spot instance and
if the bit goes beyond um that whenever
the amazon is using resources it will
basically terminate your instance and if
it if it's below you can keep your
instance and you pay only what the
instance is worth up until it reaches
your bid and anything beyond your
instance will terminate and you will
lose all the data on it so that's very
important remember
spot instances are very
often used in the environment that you
need to perform some calculation
overnight or perform some tasks like
maybe i want to spin up a server and
copy some files across
and and that's all it is and the spot
instance will be perfect for it because
it will wake up and basically perform
tasks and just shut down and
obviously there is a risk that the
instant spot instance will will be in
demand when you're performing the task
hence it will terminate or even not
launch
but
that's a risk worth taking sometimes if
you have a non-production system just to
save some money
um
i have another question can we increase
capacity in between from reserved
instance
yes we can uh
when we mean capacity once you purchase
the instance uh reserved instance you
are committed to it for a year if you
decide that you don't want this instance
after a few days or a month well in this
case sorry but amazon will not give you
refund the reason why amazon does that
is because they want to know how much
resource and how much capacity they they
must plan ahead so if enough people will
go to them and say hey i need the sample
for it for two or three four years
one or three years they'll be able to
order enough hardware to accommodate all
of that and that's the the part of that
in rewards they give you a very good
discounts because they can predict and
make sure that they have enough capacity
for everyone in the future
so
as i said already purchasing sport
strategies you can either bid
you can use bidding
a bit higher than
market price to get super overall price
that's exactly you specify let's say 20
pens uh that you bid maximum and you pay
only what the instance is worth at this
current stage which might be less or
more if it's less your instance will be
spinning if it's more your instance will
basically terminate straight away mixed
strategy which is design applications
that use a mixture of reserved on demand
and spot instances and that's a very
very common situation imagine you have a
production system on almost near
production that is not that um that is
not uh
extremely important you you might have
uh two
two servers that are actually running 24
7 because they're providing constant
traffic
and those servers it's good to actually
reserve them because you know they're
gonna be sitting there for a whole year
but then you have a little spike of
traffic and your systems added
additional boxes just to be able to
handle that well those boxes by standard
and default would be on demand which
would be a full price which is still
okay but if you want to make sure that
this particular system can handle the
traffic and be cheap then you can
actually use this as a spot instance
which means those two instances will be
bring to life
for around seven maybe eight times
cheaper than on demand perform a
specific task and die after this bike is
over so that's basically the idea of a
mixed strategy
now you have spot blocks bid for fixed
duration spot instances yes the new
feature of aws allows you to basically
uh say i need a server for three hours
and i need the server to start at maybe
10 because you have a specific task to
do and you'll be for this particular
server and you'll say hey i need this
and and and i will only pay for three
hours and they say that's fine that's
great we will give you that and you can
achieve the same principle by actually
having scheduled instance
now
caching what caching is is as simple as
uh caching data means storing previous
calculated data for you for future use
so you don't have to recalculate it and
there are two approaches application
caching and
edge caching what we would define is by
application caching this application
store and retrieve information for fast
managed in-memory cache caches this way
application can look for results in the
cache first before actually accessing
the data
you can use services like amazon
elasticash which is a service that
provides in-memory cache in the cloud
that's one of the uses another one is
edge caching it's a static content such
as images video or dynamic content um
like live video that can be cast around
the world using edge locations and for
that we would use a cloud front exactly
what we mentioned before so if you have
a website that is located maybe in the
u.s and you have a multiple users around
the world to make sure that all the
users can load a website very quickly
and it's very responsive you would
actually use um edge caching because you
would actually save all the images in a
single bucket and then get replicated
around the world in a 109 locations
where the cloud front itself which
actually makes it available everywhere
in the world hence its edge location so
you don't access the application itself
because it will go straight to the
button nearest location
security um aws provides multiple uh
security uh layers available to you and
some of them are as follows and defense
in depth
allows you to add multiple layers of
protection to your resources it's
entirely up to you how you're gonna
arrange your security aws gives you
tools and you use your tools in the way
it suits you and your business that
multiple different approaches i cannot
give you which one is the best because
it all depends on the application itself
also it gives the ability to reduce
privileged access as we mentioned before
so not everyone in your organization
must be an admin and have a full right
delete the whole account whenever they
please or they don't even know what
they're doing
security as a code you can capture all
of your security requirements in one
script that helps to deploy in your
environment and um
are they changeable as well regarding
the privileges
the question from
at least one second
we have a question from charged with
adults
chargeable as well uh privileges or or
or what exactly what's the question
about
if you if you if you if you if you're
thinking about the privileges no they're
not you can create any number of users
and all of them are for free and uh you
can change requ you can change different
privileges you can assign different
policies into it and all of this is for
free you don't pay a penny
if this is what you meant
and all the security tools as well are
free of charge aws is a very good at
that and they don't want to make money
on it they want to make sure you have
all the tools available so you secure
your platform in the end of the day you
secure also their platform so they give
you all the tools and they give you all
the knowledge you you you you you can
have in order for you to deploy the best
applications you can have
as i mentioned created the code already
and then also real-time auditing tests
and all the environments in real time as
we mentioned before you can have a log
of all the live activities on your
basically
adobe's account which allows you to have
a real-time audit um and see what
actually is going on behind the scene
now we're going to skip quickly to
monitoring and logging
monitoring and logging is
basically performed on ibs by using a
few things you can use a cloud watch
itself that is used for monitoring you
can use cloudtrail that is used for
logging and you can use
auto config which is a kind of a
combination of both because it's
actually auditing if any change occurs
in any of those which means all those
three together work
as s1
let's keep another one
so as i mentioned before what cloudwatch
does it monitors applications sorry it
monitors amazon web services resources
and applications basically it monitors
it it's like a monitor clicking and
showing you starts
collects and tracks metrics uses alarms
and sends some applications as well as
automatically make changes to the
resource based on the defined rule it
can send requests of if for example
traffic goes beyond 80
to send action to specific uh
other services to basically provision
more resources and we will actually test
this a little bit more later
what cloud watch
events are
are as follows
alerts and sends services such as aws
lambda amazon sms amazon sqs and amazon
kinesis stream
also cloudwatch events can be used to
schedule events such as snapshot or
create an instance
or instance reboot in case for example
you have instance that got stuck on a
100 cpu for very long time and you know
this application is not reproduction but
it does specific application let's say
if the instance is uh sitting on the 100
cpu for longer than 50 minutes or 30
minutes let's say you know it's not
correct and you can initiate reboot just
to make sure the instance is
healthy after it reboots and the
application can restart and stop and
work
like a charm
um i have another question here from
taranjit um are those monitoring tools
chargeable or not
the good news is cloudwatch and any of
that is not charged as a service what
you will pay is for example storage for
logs so if you're using service which
we'll discuss next um
then we can skip forward uh cloud
cloud watch logs it will allow you to
basically store the logs from any system
you want on the s3 and you only pay for
the s3 storage which is very very
minimum so um they can charge you for it
but the charge is extremely minimum and
only for storage not for the service
itself
um
okay
there are a few limits you need to
remember
you can have
up to 10 cloud watch metrics uh per
customer free of uh per month for free
anything above that and they will charge
you a very small amount of money and i
would say the amount is so little that
quite likely you can treat it almost as
free uh 10 hours per customer per month
it's it's free um that's important to
remember as well that's in a free
tier that they want to encourage
everyone to start using and testing um
in which format are those logs are
stored
challenging uh challenge is asking well
those logs are stored in the um text
file and you can you can pass them
basically very easily via any excel or
anything because most likely there are
uh either tab or space uh separated so
it's actually very easy
you can have one million api requests
for customer free for month you can have
up to 1000 amazon sms notifications per
month for free unlimited number of
custom metrics there's no limit
whatsoever you can have up to 5000
alarms per aws accounts which is a big
big number trust me on that and metrics
data is stored for two weeks and that's
important to remember
amazon wants to implement more and you
can actually have this in advance later
on probably next year they will allow
you to store it up to a year even more
but at this kind of stage it's only up
to two weeks which means if you want to
see anything beyond two weeks you will
quite likely have to use additional tool
to get your metrics out um which you can
so aws provides only up to two weeks
which is important because to remember
now cloud trail what cloud trail is it's
recording
sorry for that it's recording all the uh
api calls for the entire account
stores and reverse logs files to you in
this case it's actually s3 which means
every every single action is being
logged is being written to s3 directly
and also it provides a history of api
calls of your account every single thing
as long as it's enabled and it doesn't
have a limit it doesn't stone you for
two weeks it stores forever as it
basically uh text files you can then
text all take all your text files parse
them somehow in the way you want and
maybe ingest an application to visualize
it if you want
but you have access to it
so increase visibility
so cloud trail
one second
okay
so what uh what cloud trade provides is
increased visibility of your account
which
all the actions taken by the user at any
given time which user has taken actions
um over over a specific time period what
are the sources like p's of a given
activity and what activities fail due to
in
inadequate permissions which is
important to remember so you can use
cloudtrail to not only trace the user
but also you can use the cloud trail to
monitor if application that you for
example deployed it's maybe missing some
permissions and it's throwing some
errors so you have certain visibility
and you can adjust permissions
accordingly because it will show you
that it's missing specific permission
so also it's very important to remember
that as i mentioned before and uh all
those logs that cloudtrace is actually
generating are being stored in the s3
which means they are stored in a in a
bucket and you can basically access them
or if you want you can classify them
which means archive for cheaper storage
out of default it only stores it on this
s3 and whatever you want to do
afterwards it's up to you maybe you want
to delete those locks maybe you want um
maybe you want to copy them on prem or
or maybe you just don't care about them
at all or if you want you can basically
copy them into glass here and keep them
for long
time as a backup of all the logs
for a very very cheap price
um
also cloud trade is fully managed
service there is no management or any
any really complex configuration all you
need to do is basically enable it and
from the moment you enable that you need
to specify which bucket you want this to
go and it loads every single request
forever up until you're gonna switch it
off and as simple as this
and notifications on
a log file delivery cloudtrade uh
cloudtrail uses amazon simple
notification service also known as sns
um to notify you when the new log get
delivered and for a specific event has
occurred you can link a cloud's trail
with a notification service so for
example if the new logo gets rotated or
or or something happens it can notify
user about it
also cloudtrail itself can be integrated
with multiple different uh providers
like splunk zomological uh logi which
can actually parse and visualize those
um
in almost real time what is actually
good about it is cloud trail can be
extremely extremely big it can consist
of multiple files especially when you
have a few years of vlogs trust me you
don't want to go to those files and try
to find a single event why because you
will have to go through hundreds of
thousands of log files not only that
each file consists of hundreds of
thousands and tricks and finding a
single entry in a single file is like
looking for a needle in a haystack
almost impossible so you can link it
with other pro providers like logi or
splunk or some logic and what they will
do is they will actually you grant them
access to to your cloud trail they will
take all the logs and into their system
they will parse them
and actually they will display you some
breakdown statistics maybe you're
looking for a specific thing and you can
suddenly use search to have fully
indexed uh
uh
response and and the list so maybe
you're looking for a single user that
did something so you can search for a
username and it will
basically show you um all the records
watching this user which is much much
easier and simpler otherwise good luck
with looking through hundreds of
thousands of records
so another one a log file aggregation
it's very very
important as well cloudtrail can be
configured to aggregate log files across
multiple accounts and regions so that
the log files are delivered to a single
bucket when we use it and why imagine
you have multiple accounts because your
company wanted to do it this way imagine
you have 10 accounts now instead of
having a cloud trail for all of them log
into the same account the bucket and for
you to go in between different accounts
in fact 10 different buckets to find
something what you can do is you
configure card trail to go to a single
bucket in the single master account
which means it's much easier for you
to do it and access that as well as
other services that we mentioned before
can access everything through one bucket
rather than 10 different ones which may
might be a little bit more expensive
because they might charge you for a
bucket that's what log
file aggregation is
also you can enable encryption of all
your log files if for example your
company says you know what we don't
really want those logs to be
unencrypted because we have specific
rules and policies in here
you can enable encryption and every
single thing that ever gets created is
free encrypted with your key and ends up
in the s3 bucket then basically you need
to take this and unencrypt it with your
key and then you can access it and you
can use service called amazon key
management service also known as a kms
to do that it's very simple it's
basically two clicks and you don't need
to know anything or do anything
everything is fully automated
also a log file um provides integrity
validation what it means is that
cloudtrail logs uh stored in your s3
bucket and can detect whether whether
they're being modified changed or
deleted and and that is very important
because if for example you have a bridge
of your system and
a hacker or someone actually is uh doing
some naughty stuff on your account uh
quite likely what they will do is try to
scramble all the trial
cloud trail in order to basically hide
the activity so you will know about that
because you actually find um that those
locks were modified you can enable
versioning which means if they try to
modify the file it will still uh remain
the previous version which means even
though they will try the previous
versions will be accessible to you which
means you can still trace it
um
i have another question from china
android will this s3 bucket be private
for us means that we won't have to go to
a public or a cloud yes it actually
absolutely means this you can have s3
bucket only for internal use and you can
have a policy specified that only
specific servers or users can actually
access the bucket or if you want you can
have bucket actually facing the the
internet and by default when you create
a new bucket it's absolutely locked
which means no access externally will be
ever granted you need to enable that so
that's worth remembering very good
question
one of the last services in in this in
this section is basically uh aws config
what database config is is basically it
creates a resource inventory which means
it knows what you're currently running
and it knows uh configuration history
which means that if anything changes it
will notify you about it which means
your production system that you deployed
and you don't really want anyone to
fiddle around with it and change it you
quite likely enable config and this way
if anything changes and you will be
notified straight away and you will be
shown what actually changed
okay i have a question how config is uh
different from ops works um
well it's used in a little bit different
way adobe's configs they use as a
service to make sure that your resources
do not change so it's it's audit it's
it's a it's a it's a comparable tool
that finds if anything changes opsworks
on the other hand is it doesn't have
this feature you upload the code to
opsworks and basically deploy the
services for you the service and every
resource you need but it doesn't manage
that so if anyone actually changes ops
works increases a number of servers or
decreases or changes something you don't
know about it so uh config you can
configure config with opsworks and it
will act as an audit tool for it
so as i said before you can use uh
config rules uh by the id administrator
to quickly determine uh when and how
resources went out of compliance for
example if uh it ensures that ebs
volumes are still encrypted maybe if the
instance is still tied or maybe elastic
ap
to the instance train so you
sometimes have a systems that will be
classified as as maybe a secret or the
data on them would be
sensitive to that company and you need
to make sure that this data always
persists encrypted so if you have
multiple users in your company and you
want to make sure that the encryption is
still there you enable config and you
will make sure that
it's enabled and nothing changes and if
it does for any reason because you um
assign too much permission to colleagues
of yours that needed by maybe right
mistake or without even knowing then
what will happen is you will get
notification that suddenly the data is
unencrypted and something changed and
you get uh email or or
any other form of even text message
possible
it also provides you with configuration
visibility which means it can scan for
your configuration and if anything
changes or is abnormal to the
normal state or the one that you took a
snapshot from it will notify you via the
sms which is basically email
and
now
um
continuous assessment
assess the overall compliance of your
aws resource and preparation based on
organizations policies and guidelines
cloud governance dashboard
aws config rules give you a visual
dashboard with list charts and graphs to
help you quickly support non-compliant
resources and take appropriate action
basically a cloud
aws config will not do any action on it
it will only notify you which is
important to remember it is entirely up
to you to actually action to perform any
action or or or actually do anything
about it maybe um you have a situation
like uh you have a web server firm on
the production environment and you have
auto scaling enabled which means
maybe because of the spike
new servers were added to the pool and
you had suddenly more servers if you had
a cloud aws config enabled suddenly it
would notice that there's a difference
hey i actually noticed a few more
services it's okay it will send you
email and you can then take any action
if necessary but then you will probably
log into the console see actually there
was a spike so it's probably a false
positive and i'm not gonna act on that
but it can be helpful like suddenly uh
someone dropped a server because they
needed the wrong one which actually
happens more often than you think and
then it will you'll be notified and you
see actually uh where is my server and
then you can take action to restore the
server or maybe to find someone who did
it and say please do not do it in the
future
with the stick for example
so
one of the last subjects we're going to
discuss today
i'm song for that
is basically a hybrid id in uh
architecture what it means and how it
works and uh how to go about it
stay within one second
so
let me remove that
basically i would give you an example
like that
hybrid infrastructure is
every single time that you use
combination of a cloud
and
physical
hardware on your side or even vm
hardware
or any other resource outside of
aws
would be treated as a
basically hybrid which means you have
multiple systems in each of the of the
environments in the cloud is one of them
in a in on-prem or on data center or
anywhere else you have other bit they
both work together very well but they
consider as a hybrid and that's
basically the explanation so
um we're gonna discuss network and
infrastructure we're gonna discuss
common controls we're gonna discuss
integrate data and control and available
tools so let's jump straight into it
network so
imagine you have basically a data center
in here where you have a bunch of
servers storage databases and even users
so what would be considered as a network
a hybrid is that you still run
aws layer in here but part of your
resources are still here which means you
can have uh ec2 systems you can have
regressive databases you can have backup
systems in the glacier you can use sqs
or anything else and you connect to it
via the direct connect for example and
that would be considered as a hybrid
because portion of your systems are
still hosted in-house and another
portion is in the cloud now it's
actually very common in fact i would say
99 percent of businesses out there i
hybrid because some of them just started
the journey and just starting to migrate
systems to aws or some of them um using
aws already but they still have in-house
systems that must be present because um
of compliance or maybe data security or
something and they have a hybrid
situation
so that's a network
uh
um
i have a question from charanjit say if
we want to create a vlan uh tagging for
instances interface is that often
available in aws um
no it's not available because aws itself
does not support it if you want to
create a billion between applications
what you will do is you will actually
create a new vpc which is treated as a
biller and everything within this vpc
container itself would communicate with
each other anything outside so any
additional vlans any additional vpc you
want to create will not integrate with
that so i hope i answered your question
um so data integration and life cycle
management
enables is used to uh reliably cost
efficiently uh backup and secure your
data you can replicate data across
geographical regions uh manage the life
cycle of data or even synchronous uh in
a sync way replicate your data to a
local aws data center and it's actually
used almost every single time i can
think of it if you ever want to back up
your data yes you can use maybe dvds you
can use maybe some hard drives you can
use and even more certificate systems
like tapes or you can even have a whole
devices like netapps or or or any other
you can think of which cost hundreds of
thousands if not even millions of
dollars and it's all great you can do
that but imagine you can actually take
all the data and put it in the aws in
the s3 and then glacier it it actually
performs exactly the same you stir the
data anywhere else and somewhere else
outside of the premise which is the
point of the backup itself and you still
have redundancy and probably even more
than you would have with the tape as i
mentioned before so that's pretty much
what it is
common controls and securities and
access
you have a few ways of basically
accessing the
um the aws and integrating with this you
can use
i am so it's aws identity and access
management also for im and that is built
in aws account um
level that you can create users you can
create different uh permissions and and
you can create different policies to
grant to all those users and also use
aws directory service which is a managed
service that can link directly to your
active directory to pull a list of users
and then you can control them via your
id via this particular service and then
it allows you to actually
create um
sorry sorry my mistake uh this is where
where i meant microsoft id that fully
integrates with your on-prem
id and aws directory service is a active
directory style uh um
basically control security uh within aws
itself which integrates with microsoft
and other services but it's managed by
aws
it's a fully managed service and you can
use all three to manage majority of the
people on the on the non enterprise
versions will quite likely use this
because it's simple it doesn't require
any any um any uh
any complexity and any setup it's
basically create a user and assign
permission that's all it is
um
yes it's basically because it's right um
you can use an nfa to uh mfa which is a
multi-function a multi-factor
authentication device you can use on
pretty much all three because it fully
integrates however
i would say mfa is mostly used in here
because when you have a directory
service and even ad that quite like you
have your own version of mfa somehow
that allows you to integrate so i would
say uh the most common case is the aws
um and i am
so
common um control sensitivity access i
know it's already kind of a little bit
time-out i would say uh we're on the
slide 132 uh we have
just feels like to go maybe around five
so i hope everyone's okay we're gonna
strike the session a little bit longer
uh please let me know if it's not okay
with you um and and um
we can pause but i would prefer to
finish because it's important to me and
as well as you to actually get this all
information complete
okay i have a pretty much go ahead from
a few people that's great uh so i will
do that
now there are three types of uh
microsoft active directory uh
integration uh there is a microsoft ad
there is a simple id and there's ad
connector what they're used for and why
when you have a
let's say a big organization that you
want to integrate the
access which doesn't actually happen
that often because even if you have
organization with let's say
a million people in it if such a
condition exists
guess what not all million people will
ever access aws in fact i can bet with
you that probably less than 100 people
access it because not everyone knows and
not everyone is a system administrator i
have never ever seen anyone implementing
microsoft ad because simply there was
never a need for 50 000 users from one
company to use it most common one is
basically ions as i mentioned but if you
really have to use the 80 people often
integrate this with the ad connector
which integrates with your on-prem uh id
and pulls all the data from that simple
id is a aws
version of it which doesn't integrate
with your id itself so this one is the
most common use this one i have never
seen before and this some people are
using when they don't have ad server
itself
so
integrated resource and develop the
deployment management aws provides
monitoring and management tools with
robust apis so you can easily integrate
your aws resources with your on-site
tools and as i said before uh aws
provides you multiple tools and you can
integrate them with via the api you can
integrate with the opsworks for example
or call deploy which means you can
integrate this with your application and
you can have continuous integration and
you can initiate those to deploy new
versions of code i will show you all
those examples in the future sessions
when you're going to be focusing
directly on those
you